this is jocko podcast number 247
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
are you old enough to have a draft card
he says
yes yes i'm old enough i'm 18. we have
to have one
well do you have one yeah i say with a
full mouth sorry about that spitting
hash browns across the table
then you're old enough to enlist and get
your duty out of the way
you sure you're old enough you don't
look 18 kind of skinny too
i don't know if you'd make it through
the most basic of training
he riley smiles i'm 18 and can prove it
you want to see the card testily
reaching for my wallet
spitting a mouthful of eggs on the table
hey don't go sideways on me boy
this is a friendly conversation not a
food fight the sergeant laughs
the only thing i want you to hand me
is your bill for this meal my treat
you're trying real hard to get me to
enlist smiling i hand him the bill you a
recruiter
yes i'm a recruiter i'm staff sergeant
king
what's your name lynn lynn black
well lynn black if you volunteer you get
your choice of assignments and which
country you want to serve in how does
that sound
and behind door number two it's gotta
sound a hell of a lot better than
wandering
then wondering where you're going to
spend the night king cracks a smile
my office is right down the street
we eat afterwards i enlist
and then spend the night at the ymca
paid for by the us
army the next morning
i'm on a boeing 707 headed for a medical
examination
and basic training at fort ord
california
during basic i'm selected for the
advanced leadership school at fort knox
kentucky
before going on to the armor school
fort knox that's the place they keep all
the gold
staff sergeant king has signed me for
three years active duty
in the 13th armored career group europe
germany where i'll have access to all
the great
european art museums and the artwork of
the old masters
the army is going to pay me to tour
europe what a deal
my driving passion and greatest ambition
has always been to spend my
life as a fine art painter i've been
working at the
local seattle television station art
department all the way through high
school the art director
robert c dinsmore is a decorated world
war
ii veteran who has encouraged me to get
my military duty out of the way
the world in 1963 is a peaceful place
leave it to beaver and i love lucy are
on
television
so you might have caught that name lynn
black and it might sound familiar to you
if it does it's probably because you
heard it here
from john striker meyer aka tilt
on podcast 180 181 or 182 or maybe you
heard it from
doug the frenchman letourneau on podcast
186. like john striker meyer
and like doug letourneau lynn black was
an army soldier
a green beret and he fought in vietnam
as a member of sog the studies and
observation group a highly classified
group
that conducted missions in vietnam
cambodia
and laos they suffered over
100 percent casualties
meaning if you were a sog operator
you were going to get wounded or killed
that is how these men served
and sacrificed and before you
listen to this podcast if you haven't
listened to 180
181 182 186 and additionally
204 205 and 206 with dick thompson
go listen to them go listen to them
and you'll see that the men of sog are
true heroes heroes that conducted
completely
insane missions missions that very few
people
ever knew about and
lynn black codenamed
blackjack wrote a book about his
experiences
and i just read from that book the book
is called
whiskey tango foxtrot
wtf which we are going to dig into today
now unfortunately for a variety of
reasons
lynn could not make an appearance on
the podcast today but we were able to
bring back
tilt john striker meyer one of my heroes
who served with lynn on many operations
to talk us through the book
and provide some details that only
someone who was there
would know and understand
with that tilt thanks for coming back on
good evening sir good to be back
awesome to have you here indeed um
you you actually sent me this book do
you remember sending me this book
absolutely yeah because we did the
frenchman
and i said lynn's book was out and
lynn maurice black juniors is the man
that i
always held in the highest esteem ever
since the first time we ran into each
other for b1
at foodby in 1968. just a character yeah
well and and it's i'm hoping at some
point we have the opportunity to get him
on here
um we'll see how that plays out but
hopefully this will provide some
encouragement you know just to just to
do this section of the book and
man it's um just like every single time
i start reviewing what you guys did in
vietnam
i i just i i cannot believe what you
guys did i can't i can't believe
the level of heroism and
courage that you guys had on all these
operations
they're crazy they're freaking crazy
operations
i told you last time i said hey if i was
in charge i wouldn't have improved
any of those operations right
i remember that yeah unbelievable and
and um
and believe me i've approved some pretty
some pretty sketchy operations in my
time
but you guys took it to a whole new
level and the success that you guys had
on the battlefield was
awesome and um yeah every time i
every time i read through these books it
it just blows my mind
and it's an honor to have you on and and
to pay some kind of tribute
to what you guys did and to have you
know what you guys did was
you know that's that's my heritage you
know even though i'm in the navy you're
in the army
i mean just the special operations what
you guys did over there
was just laid the groundwork and and set
the bar
so high for the rest of us forever
oh well thank you well and you know and
i'm glad you're reading wtf
because lynn's just one of those
characters i mean of all the stories for
sog for eight years
if you put down some of the most
harrowing stories the top five for eight
years lynn's gotta be right near the top
if not the top one that's why i'm glad
we're gonna dig into it a little bit
today
just to pay homage to a man that i've
respected from day one and you guys did
and i don't think we're gonna go into
this part today but you got he
but when we covered across the fence and
on the ground
you you and lynn worked together for how
long how long were you guys actually
working together
uh he ran a he's he came on our team for
a few minutes
as a strap hanger right and then we went
down to ccn
in the january of 69 then he came on the
team
bubba sure left lynn came on and then
our little people loved them plus they
knew him from october
and so when i left i just turned the
team over to him i just
knew the team was in good hands i never
worried about it i came back
lynn was the 1-0 that was his 1-1 for a
while
and then we took turns and then they
finally just said hey you got too much
experience here
black and then yanked him and put him in
some special projects that
he went off and did and i took over
idaho and went back to running just
simple recon
where lynn was doing some some
classified stuff
all right well let's get a little bit
let's learn a little bit of about
lynn black and where he came from i'm
going to go to the book here
and it says this in the category of
common things that go unnoticed in the
world while ho chi minh was working for
the oss
saving allied lives lynn maurice black
jr
was born to lynn senior and violet black
of albany oregon lin jr
that's me this is where i come into the
picture
i was immediately given the name bosco
when my mother found
that by mixing a bit of the chocolate
drink into my baby milk i dozed right
off
in berlin what is bosco what is it of
some kind of old-school chocolate drink
or something
like hershey's chocolate okay yeah i've
never had boss i don't know how that
missed me because i'm a chocolate milk
kind of fiend
he goes on here in berlin germany on the
date an hour of my birth
at 10 a.m on april 22nd adolf hitler
declared to his general staff that
germany had lost the war
and that he would commit suicide in 19
and here's the caveat or here's the
warning i'm skipping through this book
i'm not going to read the whole thing
so if it seems a little bit chopped up
that's why you got to get the book
he fast forward here in 1946 my mother
was pregnant with my brother hugh
we lived in salem oregon where my father
worked
for the post-war state employment office
the war machine was winding down and
unemployment was high i was
one year old april 1947 on my second
birthday
we moved to the corner of 123 bomb
and 456 detonator ordnance
oregon which was a munitions depot town
for world war ii
war supplies my father managed the
payroll office for the depot
that's just pretty much the coolest
place the coolest address isn't that
great
that's perfect for lynn oh yeah yeah
yeah no doubt about it blowing things up
oh yeah
in 1950 i was five when the korean war
broke out
we had moved down the road to hermiston
oregon
and our father had taken a job with the
guy f atkinson construction company as
the head of their payroll
office our mother had purchased a small
road house
diner after that
my brothers hugh bruce
and i were on our own i was the little
man
bosco the babysitter in that same year
the soviet union recognized ho chi
minh's government
even though vietnam was recognized
internationally as part of
french indochina joseph stalin convinced
ho that the soviet union would bankroll
his fight against the french
if he agreed to allow chinese advisers
to train
sixty to seventy thousand viet men
hoe bit his lip and agreed to china's
support which enabled him to escalate
his
fight against france in 1953 the korean
war ended i was eight years old
in the third grade and in love with the
red-headed freckle face girl next door
on march 13th 1954
with the monetary backing of the soviets
and chinese
advisors the viet minh engaged the
french at denbien
few on march 23rd the viet man
captured the main airstrip resulting in
partial isolation of french army units
inclement weather closed in on the area
preventing air drops of supplies
evacuation of the wounded
or close combat air support as the
french
ran ever lower on supplies and
casualties mounted the viet minh
took control of the countryside when the
french could no longer patrol they were
forced into purely defensive positions
which were shelled with big guns several
times a day
on april 7 1954 dwight d eisenhower gave
his domino theory speech
during a news conference declaring
finally
you have broader considerations that
might follow what you would call
the falling domino principle
you have a row of dominoes set up you
knock over the first one
and what will happen to the last one is
the certainty that it will go
over very quickly
so you could have a beginning of a
disintegration
that would have the most profound
influences
nine days later vice president richard
nixon announced that the united states
may be putting our own boys in indochina
regardless
of allied support
it's it's always important to me to roll
through kind of the way these things
unfold and and pay attention to them
history yeah and we're living it right
now you know and
and i was talking to a friend of mine
the other day
and it seems like maybe we're not
always part of history maybe the 90s
right what was going on the night so
the berlin wall came down so that was
kind of historical but then it was down
and
and there was kind of some time where
you feel like how much are we really a
part of history that people will
be reading about and then things happen
like what's going on right now and 9 11
and
the wars in iraq and afghanistan and you
start realizing oh no we're
we're unfortunately gonna play we're
gonna we're gonna have our own history
as well
and when you read things like this it it
makes a connection for me
that you better remember that what's
happening this could
this could always escalate things could
always go in a direction that you didn't
anticipate
a little usa can lead to mighty big
troubles later down the road
crazy oh yeah
on may 7th the epic battle of denver
diane bien phu
ended in a french defeat the viet minh
shot the wounded and marched the
ambulatory french to the coast where
they were loaded on
ships and sent packing back to france
the french government did not want their
citizens to know the defeat and refuse
to allow their brave soldiers
to disembark from the ships
many brave french soldier citizens
died in the holes of those ships
diem bien feu was the first time a
non-european colonial independence
movement had evolved
through all the stages from guerrilla
bands to a conventionally organized and
equipped army able to defeat a modern
western occupier in pitched battle
april 22 1957 i turned 12
and announced i was no longer to be
called bosco
my name is lin and i wanted to be called
by my real name besides kids my age were
teasing the hell out of me
when they found out my real name things
got worse
lynn what a [ __ ] name this began a boy
named sioux
era that never ended never so he thought
he was
look everyone's making fun of my
nickname bosco that's mean i'm just
going to go with my real name
lin yeah
[Music]
in june of 1963 i graduated from rainier
beach high school in seattle washington
i was sleeping late on saturday morning
when
wake up orders my father shaking my
shoulder i'm awake barely what's going
on
are you going back to work at the
television station mom asks
not today it's saturday i give them my
best 18 year old smart ass smile
i quit the station six months before
graduation to pay attention to a sagging
grade average
i think i'm going to take the summer and
just goof off
do you plan on using either your
scholarships my father needles me
knowing i have no intention of going to
college i went to college he chides
maybe art school but no college it would
be a waste of my time and everybody's
money
i thought we already had this
conversation i reply yawning
[Laughter]
don't be a smart ass promise mom do you
have enough money saved up to pay rent
purchase your own food and
transportation
i thought i'd live here during the
summer and go back to work in the fall
then i'll get a place in my own how
about that if you live here you'll pay
rent
not the kind of rent you pay now but the
kind of rent as if you had your own
place
you'll be out of money pretty fast
you'll need a job understand
you heard what your mother said father
insists
i don't have the savings to pay that
kind of rent i groggily complain
i would really like to take a break
after graduation
i take it what you really want is to get
me out of the house growing up
both of my parents had worked and i was
responsible starting at the age of five
for taking care of my two brothers
the little man and they called me better
than my other name bosco
i've been working and saved my money
since i was 15.
all i want to do is take the summer off
go back to work and then get an
apartment
can't this one wait the summer
sounds to me like we aren't looking at
the same road map
mom says firmly both your brothers
are old enough to take care of
themselves and your father is retired
and at home
this evening is your last free meal here
understand
yep sure do stark naked
i jump out of bed and boldly head for
the shower boy this pisses me off why
the hell can't they wait until the fall
when i come out they're gone i dress
walk a mile to the bus stop
and head for the seattle pike place
market to get something to eat and
wander around the open-air art galleries
what am i going to do
so at that point you know this is when
he goes and he actually meets that
recruiter so that's why that recruiter
can tell that he's kind of got nowhere
to go
and he starts his uh
starts his journey sergeant king gets
him in yep sergeant king man scored at
the diner
yeah paid that bill and made his quota
yeah
uh he goes continues on here while at
armor school an
airborne recruiter dangles the
possibility of an extra
55 dollars a month in addition to my
meager monthly 79
dollar base pay if i am only
man enough to make three parachute jumps
sounds as easy as falling out of an
airplane i volunteer a second time
this volunteering thing is getting to be
a habit 134 monthly for a pfc
close along with three hots and a cot
that's crazy that you guys got that much
money for going to airborne school
55 yeah it might not seem like a big
deal
except for that i think i got 110
in like 1990. where my base pay
was probably a thousand bucks you know
what i'm saying so it was like one tenth
of my base pay
where you guys were getting almost
double your base pay oh yeah in my case
i was getting 50
a week because i'm not sure where lynn
got that inflated salary
because i was getting 50 and the jump
school was 55 dollars so he's like
100 plus and i'm in
so he goes to jump school at fort
benning georgia yeah which is where i
was lucky enough to go they don't send
navy guys there anymore
where do they send them they go to yuma
yeah they go somewhere else
yeah yumo or actually it might be here
in san diego but they you basically go
and learn
it's more of a gentleman's course you
know and it's faster
and you go you get more experience
really quick yeah because that three
weeks can be consolidated
oh you think but i had a great time at
airport school man
it was awesome um
and then he goes to a heavy drop school
learning i guess how to how to get
everything rigged up to throw out of the
back of airplanes
oh yeah and then he says this after
several weeks of rigor training i
receive orders for delta company
16th armor 173rd airborne brigade
in okinawa hey
okinawa is not a city in germany this is
not what i signed up for for an extra 55
bucks a month i've
blown away a european tour in art
education
but i can rig heavy supply loads and
vehicles for such snatch outs at high
level drops
now there's something i can use in the
civilian life black you dumbass
the 173rd had had been activated in june
1963 the same month i had graduated from
rainier beach high school in seattle the
173rd
has assumed the assets of the second
airborne battle group
then stationed on okinawa just south of
japan the 173rd
the 173rd mission is to quickly close
with and destroy the enemy
forces using fire maneuver and shock
action in coordination with other armed
forces
it was because of its many parachute
exercises on taiwan
that the members of the 173rd earned the
respect and admiration of the
nationalist
chinese soldiers so impressed with the
paratroopers of the 173rd were the
chinese that they nicknamed
the men of the brigade tin being or sky
soldiers the name stuck the pentagon's
public expectation of us is that we can
be deployed within 24 hours to any hot
spot in the pacific theater
engage with and deter an enemy for 72
hours
this delaying suicidal action would
allow
time to deploy real forces such as the
marines
thank god there aren't any hot spots to
be deployed to
thank god this is the peacetime army and
having
no enemy tonight let's go to the ville
and get drunk we'll watch the strip
shows
life's good on the rock that's what the
jarheads call okinawa and i'm fast
forwarding through some other stuff but
he's he's there you know he's there he's
kind of doing the peacetime
army thing um
living the dream march 14th 1965
is the 19th birthday of hugh robert
black
one of my younger brothers that morning
he arrives on okinawa
with the future third platoon leader
first lieutenant richard
h goldsmith pfc hugh is assigned to the
173rd
engineering company i'm happy to see him
all the way through school i admired
hugh's scholastic capability and am
admittedly
envious of his high grade point average
and seemingly easy learning style both
of us have enlisted
voluntarily to do our duty and then
return
to pursue life
why the hell didn't i just go to art
school because you're doing your duty
dimwit
shut up put your head down and just get
it done and stop talking to yourself
or they think you belong here
permanently yeah the way he's written
this book he's got all kinds of these
italicized sections where he's kind of
just given his own thoughts
oh yeah and and they're they're they're
awesome to read
um
the rich mind of lynn black yeah it's
just funny no matter what you talk to
him about
like that stuff there particular his
self-examination
and his commentary it's just like yeah
and
i i'm not gonna get too much into it but
the way this book is written a lot of it
is written and i'll try and explain
a lot of is written as conversations
that are debriefs either debriefs
official debriefs or
unofficial debriefs that you guys have
in your
in your team room yeah with beers and
playing dice
and then between stream of consciousness
right
he gets a hot streak going you can just
hear the keys going
and they'll take a break for a beer when
he comes back yeah the atmosphere that
he gives out of the team room
of you guys is pretty awesome and you
guys playing
playing freaking liars dice all the time
and and the little
uh those those little debrief sessions
though
he mentions it that's how you were
learning
oh yeah that's that's where you were
figuring out what to do and what
mistakes this group made and what these
guys did right what they did wrong and
those those those sessions where you're
giving each other a bunch of [ __ ] but
you're also
passing valuable information on oh
absolutely particularly in our early
time at fob1
that's what we learned was from the
senior ncos and any other team member
that been on the ground
we faithfully made a point of talking to
them some wouldn't some couldn't
too much trauma but the ones who would
talk
i mean pat watkins spider parks
john mcgovern they're all men that we
just admired and they took time to talk
to us
we could ask them questions and then we
got the flying cubby we'd hear about the
mission what went wrong
always trying to improve the tactics
to see what uh we could do to improve
when we get in the field
we did when you did you say when you got
to flying covey
well well spider parks became covey
right pat watkins after time on the
ground
got it they were our best coffee riders
got it and so
at the end of 68 particularly the
october 5th mission they were both
alternating on station that day it was
so historic
part of that historic moment in time
that missionary
and so before that like during september
and august
uh pat had run several missions out of
fob three
in the layoffs and then we talk you
always learn stuff we just sat there and
just tried to sponge it in
bring it in yeah and we'll get to some
of uh lynn's
vietnam experience prior to being in sog
and prior to being in special forces but
for someone like you and we talked about
this
in in across the fence i mean is
crazy that you were how old were you on
your first mission
22 yeah well
i was old by some students i i spent two
years in college trying to flunk out
there you know
but by august of 68 they that's when
they finally after that uh
attack at fob4 um they came up with the
idea of putting together
a 1-0 school so they would train but
there was nothing in place so when we
got to fu by
may and june man you just talked to the
men who would talk to you
anybody had any experience at all like
john walton came back from two or three
really bad targets
we talked to him because we're both well
he was a high powered e4 i was just low
private but anybody who would talk we
talked that's where well you're right
that clubhouse was
uh better than anything we could get in
terms of really learning
what was going on on the ground air
assets weather
and the reality of the of the king bees
what we worked with at the time it's one
thing to talk about in training
helicopter come pick you up well you
gotta have other conditions there
man you know how that goes yeah
crazy uh so now we get to 1965.
and lynn says somewhere in the middle of
april 1965
cryptic rumors begin to spread rampantly
from company to company around the
brigade
hq directs all training to cease and
practice mount outs be conducted which
is them basically gearing up to go
oh yeah shortly the company receives its
basic load of live ammunition
and begins to prepare all vehicles for a
combat check
man these rounds are heavy complains one
of the new loaders
april 22nd 1965. man he nails these
dates in here
oh yeah it makes me wish i would have
kept the journal which i never did
me too april 22 1965
i celebrate my 20th birthday
may 2nd rumors begin to fly as word
spreads that key personnel have received
advance
party orders to an unknown destination
may 3rd company commander joseph c
jordan jr at last announces the
destination
and he says i have just come from
general williamson's morning briefing
what i'm about to tell you is a
chronology of events leading to a
temporary offshore assignment
on april 24th the general received a top
secret message from general westmoreland
to meet him in saigon
saigon south vietnam at mcv headquarters
it seems there's a guerrilla war being
waged in that southeast asian country
the 173rd is to be a part of what is
called
rolling thunder being conducted by the
u.s air force out of bases
in that country what we heard this
morning is that the army of the republic
of vietnam known as the arvins are
having difficulty providing
adequate security for the air bases and
supporting rolling thunder raids
the arvin the arvins are also having
difficulty performing
offensive operations against the
guerrillas known as viet cong
or vc general williamson also revealed
that
several u.s divisions are scheduled to
arrive in south vietnam within months
the 173rd's mission is to clear the
incoming unit's proposed base camp sites
of
the vc our deployment will be a
temporary one
probably not lasting more than 60 days
the advanced party will leave
for bien hoa republic of south vietnam
the 173rd is to conduct a security
action
the ceo announces that he thinks we'll
be back on oki
for sure by christmas
our first mission is to secure patrol
and neutralize
any threat to bin hoa air base
which is our base camp area you all now
know about
as much about this assignment as i do
so there you go these guys go from not
even knowing that there was anything
going on in vienna i was thinking how
different that is now
yeah you know because when there's some
kind of action taking place in the world
everybody knows about it instantly you
know you know about it instantly because
you look at your phone
and there's the news and whether it's
iraq or afghanistan or somalia or
wherever
everybody knows when there's something
happening in the world and here these
guys
they're not they don't have any idea
what's happening in vietnam and they're
on the rocks they're not getting the new
york times or any other newspaper
that by that time had carried stories
for a few years and pissed off president
kennedy
pissed off lbj but uh so
they missed that and so here's lynn like
oh
you're gonna go to benoit it will only
beer 60 days
not
uh he goes into this thing about how
they had to dye their their underwear
green
um on may 4th the company receives word
we are to delete nine spats from our
inventory and replace them with the m113
armored personnel carriers or apc
so this is 1965. yeah
and you know what we use for kazovac
vehicles in the battle of ramadi in 2006
m113s m113s
which almost any bullet could still
penetrate
yeah my uh my commanding officer one
time you know he's he was talking me
through an operation that the guys were
going out on
and he said what's the kazovac plan i
said hey the kazvak plan is this we'll
contact this company they have 113s
they'll come out
and he says what if what if that
113 hits a subsurface ied so
at the time subsurface ied had it
everybody knew what that was and what it
was was somebody the enemy would bury
the the explosives you know
underneath the ground and you couldn't
see them so it wasn't like something
sitting on the side of the road it was
under the ground and they would make
them big
and he says well what will happen if
that 113 hits a
hits a subsurface ied and i said sir if
the 113 hits a subsurface ied everyone
in that 113 is going to be dead
and that was the facts you know that was
the fact that it's going to be their
casket
the really weird thing is
most at that time including the 113 the
abrams
all these older vehicles the when you
build those vehicles you build them as
low as the to the ground as you can at
the lowest possible profile
so that you can't be seen it's like
ducking right you build the even a
humvee's built like that
right a home v is wide but it's low sure
and
an abrams is is wide but it's low and a
113 is low to the ground they don't have
much clearance
because you know you don't want to get
shot at by another tank so you can hide
behind you know a little ridge line or a
little
knoll or something like that the problem
is that's the worst possible vehicle to
have when it comes to getting blown up
from the ground and so now you when you
see the
the mine resistant vehicles now they're
massive they're tall you've got to get a
lot
you get into them with a ladder you
literally there's a ladder there's like
five
four or five rungs on a ladder to get up
into them because they're built really
high
and you exit with a parachute yeah they
have a v-shaped hole
that deflects the blast as well and a
113 has
a complete flat bottom it's super low to
the ground
but they were just they weren't this was
not the problem that they were coming up
against at that time
oh yeah may 5th
the company begins feverishly working to
prepare our vehicles for shipment the
following day
may 6th we are we drive to okinawa
to the okinawa port of naha where the
vehicles are loaded under the direction
of lieutenant gilmore the embarkation
officer
and again i'm just jumping through this
stuff you got it's so great to read this
you got to get this book
because the details that he gives i
don't know how he's got a way better
memory than me
right dates are logged down names and
for everyone
i mean who remembers the name of the
damn embarkation officer
he must have written that down he has to
but it's great it makes you feel like
you're there you're right there perfect
absolutely yeah
uh the 173rd airborne brigade is the
first u.s
army unit sent to vietnam can you
imagine so talking about history
oh yeah may 12 at 12
16 hours company d 16th armor arrives in
saigon harbor
the paris of southeast asia
company d's first combat assignment
comes in the form of ambush patrols
we're ordered to attach 12 enlisted
personnel each day to the first the
503rd for a three-day period
so much for riding on tracks so they got
all these vehicles but now they're going
out on patrols
needs of the army do they say needs of
the army no okay in the navy that's like
a kind of a joke
someone will say well what do you think
your job's gonna be it's like no needs
in the navy
well it's like whatever the navy needs
you to do you're gonna do
i think oh yeah and even though they
might not say that in the army
that's the way it is because we don't
care if you've been trained on these
tracks to
to fight from armor you're going to go
out you're going to be on foot patrol
may 18th our vehicles arrive and the
company turns to the task of prepping
them
thank god now now maybe we can start
doing stop doing patrols with the grunts
i'm an armored guy not a ground pounder
one track crew member complains and
here's lynn's thoughts i disagree with
that no one in their right mind wants to
be walking this miserable place when you
can be riding
oh sorry i agree with that no one in
their right mind wants to be walking
this miserable place when you can be
riding
who the hell wants to sleep on the
stinking wet ground with bug snakes and
god knows what else god damn it
i'm supposed to be in europe
[Laughter]
well it is the paris of the orient
uh may 19th the first platoon is
attached to the three
third three 319th artillery for a
security mission the remainder of the
month is spent training and seemingly
endless
improvement of the defensive perimeter
here's here's here's lynn's thoughts dig
endless trenches
trenches fill sandbags build bunkers
string concertina wire
put up tents wind and rain flood the
trenches and bunkers and flatten the
tents
put up tents again go out on patrol with
ground pounders
pull kp stand guard duty how in the hell
can any of these lifers do this for a
living
i'm so tired of pots and pans duty i
could kill somebody there's a thought
so that's how they psychologically
prepare us pots and pans
[Laughter]
on the last day of may general
williamson initiated a four-day
operation
three objectives were hit by our sky
soldiers
casualties were few against light
resistance though our guys experienced
no heavy fighting the operation the
first
u.s offensive action in south vietnam
greatly contributed to the confidence of
the 173rd
airborne brigade
the first operation of july is search
and destroy
in conjunction with elements of the 1st
battalion 503rd infantry
july 16th the company in conjunction
with elma's the first the 503rd
and the engineering company conduct a
search and destroy operation
during that operation my younger brother
hugh is critically wounded
by an unseen enemy during a mortar
attack
and several of his friends are killed
he's medevaced out of the ao and back to
conus so
you know i kind of drifted through that
part where his brother showed up on
okinawa well his brother
they're both at the same unit they end
up deploying to vietnam the first
americans in vietnam
and his brother ends up getting wounded
by a mortar pretty bad
and here's lynn's thoughts on that you
[ __ ] not my brother
not my brother show yourselves you
cowards god damn it
here we are driving up and down the
roads while those bastards are hiding in
the bushes
bushes they can see us but we can't see
them where the hell are they
somebody has to know where they are i'm
sorry hugh i hope you can forgive me
i should have been there with you i'll
find them they'll pay
i promise welcome to the jungle baby
that's one of the things that you know
uh
when i was in ramadi i would always read
the book about face you know by by david
hackworth and
and one of the things that was so
similar
was what just happened right there this
is the beginning of the war
and you're fighting against an enemy
that you can't see right and it's
so frustrating especially for the
conventional troops that are out there
and
and you know i was talking about this
today with a client
the the mentality
and what it does to your mentality of
being on offense versus being on defense
and when you got on you when they we
know when when the mission is go out and
walk down this road
you might think you're being on offense
but if you think about it a little bit
deeper you're on defense
because you're walking down that road
and they can have booby traps and
ieds and snipers and mortars they can
have all that stuff
and you are on defense even though
you're moving you're on defense
and that was definitely how i felt on my
first deployment
same thing i would ask like young junior
officers i'd say
is this an offensive operation i talk
about a direct action mission in
downtown baghdad i show him a profile of
a mission and i'd say
is this an offensive operation they go
absolutely and i go how long are you on
offense for
because the whole mission takes an hour
and a half two hours
right so you drive from baghdad to some
other part of baghdad it takes you
half an hour to get there and then you
hit the target it takes 15 minutes
and then you drive back so it's another
half an hour so you were out for an hour
and 15 minutes i would say
how much time were you on offense for
and then they'd start thinking about it
sometimes they'd say the whole time
we're always on offense
and i'd say well that sounds good but
it's not true
it's not true when you're out on patrol
when you're moving
through enemy territory you are on
defense
you're a target you're a target now once
you get to that target and you set up
believe me we go on offense for a good
solid three or four minutes
but then even once we hit the target now
all the bad guys know we're there
and now we're on defense again so that
what that does to your mentality is
it can be hard on people it can be hard
to be constantly paranoid and constantly
on defense
and it's the same thing in life right
you know somebody was asking me
what do you do and you know what do you
do when you've got all these things are
happening and the market's changing
and i said look you can either be on
defense and try and just keep it
together which doesn't feel good
or you can look at the problem go on
offense and attack the problem
and that's exactly the mentality that
lin's having right here he wants to go
on the attack
oh yeah absolutely
[Music]
continuing on the 173rd along with other
american units and vietnamese troops
work together to break the siege of
special forces
at camp do duke co
am i saying that right duco duco
captain jordan d the delta company
commander leads
his company on foot patrols to an
exploit to exploit a suspected vc
stronghold
as well as other armored patrols and
security details
sir captain jordan let me go with you on
the patrols
no black you aren't any shape to be
going with us i need soldiers
not a revenge squad yeah
so black's getting left behind and he
wants to go get after it
and his boss is saying you just need to
you need to slow your roll
black august 6th
company d ferries the royal australian
regiment infantry to their area of
operations august 17th
the second and third platoons along with
command track lead for extended
operation
september 9th 1965 captain joseph c
jordan
relinquishes his command for a staff
position with the great
brigade hq captain john e dunlop jr
formerly
hq company commander is recipient of
the guide on
while on patrol platoon sergeant herman
trent
spec 5 carrillo pfc's henry s
baker and robert l adams are all wounded
when they come under heavy mortar fire
by the still unseen enemy
s spec 4 craig is credited with saving
two lives and later receives the
soldiers medal
commendation october 8th 1965
company d departs our ben hoa
[Music]
base for the iron triangle on a search
and destroy operation
not far down the road around the first
bend a command detonated mine is set
off by the vc completely destroying the
apc
killing the driver pfc michael brancato
and severely wounding staff sergeant
saint clair
westerman and samson moore
son of [ __ ] blew us up westerman
later slurs through his wired jaws he's
trying to explain to me what happened
blew the goddamn track off the pc and
flipped it upside down
killed brancato good kid
god damn it on and on it went
warzone c and d the iron triangle
op plans new life and smash in december
search and destroy and convoy security
along with blocking force missions that
first tour of duty rolled on much the
same way as it did the first six months
until specialist fourth class lynn
m black jr got promoted
then i went back to the world in july of
1966
later that year i appeared on a
television morning show hosted by a guy
named
princeton preston price at king tv
seattle washington so here he is he's
out of the army
yeah with me was an army helicopter
gunner who had become a war protester
the door gunners mantra for the 30
minute show was that the united states
had no business being in southeast asia
why would communists on the other side
of the world have any effect on our
american freedom
he didn't believe that any young man of
draft age had any responsibility to
fight any legal war
we needed to question the use of illegal
authority
this is more than i can take and i
accuse the gunner of being a coward and
a traitor to his country
i immediately launched into a duty honor
country speech
that would have shamed any man
it certainly did me what i wanted to do
was kick the unseen enemy's ass for
whacking hue
it didn't make a dent in the door
gunner's resolve and the two of us
morning show guests began to talk over
the top of one another as the lights
were switched off in the studio
and the station went into a prolonged
set of live beer and appliance dealer
commercials
in an adjacent studio
the unseen enemy killed several of my
fellow soldiers
and had severely wounded many more my
brother and my best friend had been
crippled
for life or grotesquely wounded i can't
say for sure i ever saw the face of the
enemy during that tour of duty
sitting in my apartment in hawaii
watching the evening news i felt guilty
pissed off alone and completely consumed
by feelings of revenge
u.s planes began bombing hanoi
we see you now you sons of [ __ ] north
vietnam
north vietnam declares general
mobilization the warsaw pact promises to
support north vietnam
whiskey tango foxtrot i'm re-enlisting
and if anyone hasn't figured out what
wtf whiskey tango foxtrot stands for
it stands for what the [ __ ] over
[Laughter]
so that's his first tour of duty and
it's crazy to think he's saying hey i
don't even think i ever saw the enemy
during that and he's got his brother
wounded he's got other guys wounded and
killed and never saw the enemy
yeah and they had a couple times
i forget how detailed he went in that
first part but
when they were in the apc's
they got in the into the um rubber
plantations
we had rows and rows of trees you figure
you go in there and
hey man we can figure it out well they
didn't and they got
hammered in there i remember lynn
talking about that
both in both tours of duty at some point
we got into a reflection thing
he he would go back once a while but the
rubber plantations
and then between the snipers and their
controlled fire lanes and obviously they
set things up in practice before
173rd ever got there and then they had
to be careful not to damage any rubber
trees that they did
the plantation owners would they come
back and sue the united states to pay
for the damaged rubber trees
vietcong well you know he can't deal
with them but politics and but that
story
and the apc is that thin armor
oh he had some nightmares i just can't
imagine
and that's a traditional unit yeah early
on
and they learned some lessons the hard
way boy
yeah you know the um when i did um
lewis puller junior's book on here
um fortunate son and he's go he's
rotating
between three areas and you know like
one of them was bridge security one of
them was camp security and then one of
them was called
the riviera i think or the rivera but
every time they'd go out there they'd
get take take casualties and they'd
never see
the enemy and they would do a high five
with you know their platoon was heading
out there's another platoon rotating
back in
yeah i forget it was a tuner company i
think it was platoon platoon size
he'd be heading out he'd high five you
know the other platoon commander
and you know the guy would say yeah we
took two casualties of three casualties
we cas evac them out did you see the
enemy nope
so you're just going out there and
taking hits
and you don't see the enemy
and that that's very similar to iraq you
know very similar to iraq where
many much of the time guys be out there
they just get blown up by an ied or you
get hit by mortar fire you get hit by
sniper fire
and that's uh that's the way that's the
way the guerrillas fight against a
against america absolutely and then even
with the
snipers they knew how to get back in the
building so they fired out
there'd be no direct smoke or evidence
of them where the rounds came from you
really had to
uh have good ear detection or some kind
of sensor
yeah that sixth sense to figure out
where the hell the rounds were coming
from i think it would have to be a sixth
sense because you can't tell from
where those rounds are coming from no
that goes in this
and you see you see in movies you know
there's always a sniper in a window and
his barrel sticking two feet out of the
window
but you're right the snipers are
actually not even in that room
they're in a room deep one room deep
maybe even more down a hallway
so their field of vision is tiny but you
there's no possible way that you're
seeing them
no
[Applause]
but luckily some people learn to uh
adapt and take the fight to the enemy
indeed july 1968
and these are some thoughts during my
first tour with the 173rd i watched them
special forces and other recon men from
the herd
which is the nickname which is a great
nickname for the 173rd
the herd from the herd
marine force recon the 82nd and 101st
airborne divisions there's something
different special about recon men
i can't quite put my finger on it but i
sure as hell
want to be one intense yet always joking
around it was like they were fighting a
different war than the rest of us
everyone knew they were the best of the
best
we graduated from company b special
forces training group
fort bragg north carolina at the
beginning of the class
had been 500 of the finest physically
fit soldiers ever produced in the united
states army
that may 1968 graduating class contained
less than 70 men
standing at attention proudly waiting to
be awarded the coveted
green beret when did you graduate from
special forces training
december 67. so you're already
you're already done and he's a new guy
yeah i'm in camp i'm an fb1 waiting for
lynn to get there
we had earned the right to work with the
best of the best hell we were the best
and he kind of just runs through some of
the special forces training back then
in the beginning phase one we sat in the
classroom for eight hours a day
listening to lectures and taking notes
we were given homework assignments
papers to write and participated in
small
in class and after class working teams
half the group was eliminated
in phase one every day we heard phrases
like if i wanted to sit on my ass all
day in a classroom i joined the air
force
this is college prep school this is
college prep school nonsense
a lot nonsense a lot of what it took to
get through phase one was
attitude of willingness being willing to
adore the unexpected
i don't think any of us expected the
classroom did you spend that much time
in the classroom
oh yeah what were you guys learning
about
well they they all the indoctrination
stuff
the history and then um procedures then
like
our comma class you sat down you're in
that class for eight to ten hours just
there taking camo
and um land navigation all kinds of
different things like that you had to
take notes i remember
well i'm packing the move now going
through finding some of my old notes
back that's like
oh my god i forgot about that that's
like i got it out of my mind
when you find those notes just take a
picture of them and send him to me so we
can talk about him at some point that
sounds freaking awesome
i got this book that i wrote when i was
a
e5 in the seal teams and i was teaching
i was teaching communications
and i found it it just says seal team
one communications
and it's basically on how to work the
different radios but then in the back i
have a section called
lessons learned i'm going to cover it on
the podcast because it's legit
is that right yeah maybe we have to go
back and compare notes
indeed got a little morse code training
you know oh i was one of the last guys
that had to learn morris code
yeah did he done dumb did he yeah my uh
the guy that was teaching us to it
because there was people that were
pushing back like we don't need to learn
morse code you know we have
satellites now and this guy says in the
event of what was his phrase
he said uh in the event of a nuclear
war the only thing that's going to be
punching through the ionosphere is
hfcoms yeah and morris code
so we gotta learn it of course i'm 19
years old i'm totally
down i'm like cool if there's a nuclear
war i'm ready to make comms
yeah they don't teach you it in basic
seal training
there is no mental challenge whatsoever
i mean there's no
you don't sit in a classroom you don't
sit in a classroom probably
ever for more than like an hour when
they're trying to teach you dive physics
or hydrographic reconnaissance
it's just totally they don't do that
with us that's why you get some knuckle
draggers in the teams
yeah yeah
you know the special forces guy just you
know they got they like that they like
that kind of thing
they like that kind of thing being a
little bit smarter
um during phase two we were divided
amongst our various specialty groups
such as operations intelligence medical
weapons and so on i was the hands-on
portions
this was the hands-on portion training
in my case i was being trained as a
weapons
specialist which i imagine everybody
wants to be
oh yeah boy toys to the max
yeah and and how do they pick what
you're gonna do um
they gave you tests and then they're
supposed to
indicate what you're good at and then
there's needs what the army needs needs
of the army yeah
and you ended up comms yeah i ended up
comms too
because i had this um
i stood watch at the seal team one
quarter deck
like a new guy you're gonna stay and
watch and so i'm standing watch i'm
standing with this this
officer he's a like a platoon commander
but he's you know more experienced than
me and he's talking to me and
we we have to stay there the whole night
you know we're like sleeping in the bunk
beds or whatever
to make sure no one attacks seal team
one this is like 1991.
and the guy after talking to me he says
you know what you know when he's asking
me well
what are you what are you joining the
seal teams for you don't want to be an
operator i want to go on missions right
and he's in the morning he says hey you
know what what you should do is you
should
go to the radio room
tomorrow or or when you when we get off
and go tell me you want to be a radio
man because the radio man
always goes on operations as though he
is the only guy that's going on every
operation
i mean the medic kind of but the radio
men for sure
have to and so i went up got off a watch
went right up banged on the radio i want
to be a radio man
why i want to go on every operation cool
right on sign up here i was probably the
only person in the history of seal team
one to do that
because what does everyone else want to
do they want to be a machine gunner and
a sniper
oh yeah they want to be a weapons guy
[Music]
[Applause]
so fast forward a little bit he's home
in seattle on leave he's got some of his
sf buddies with him uh named bob and
steve
and here they are kind of hanging out
with hugh and here we go
hugh one of my two younger brothers has
joined us during our last last
afternoon out on our sister carla's back
deck
this is our last day in the civilian
world this is before they go on
deployment
he's wearing a tank top and t-shirt and
a pair of shorts
which shows off the scar running from
one knee up the length of his leg to his
hip
after a couple beers he tells the story
about the mortar attack
his leg wound broken ribs arm and
shrapnel
filled face and torso he recount
recounts the month spent recovering
at madigan army hospital
bob and steve are visibly shaken by the
sight of wounds
and more so by the story of inadequate
medical treatment
and disdain from the hospital staff for
anyone dumb enough to get suckered into
volunteering for nom
the mood of the afternoon darkens and
alcohol consumption
increases
last day gillette softly drones yup give
me a beer
how do you say this and get engelke how
do you say his name do you know
uh angle key angle key steve bob uh
gillette those are his two buddies oh
yeah oh it's gillette
okay and gelkay gel k
uh ankle key ankle key man i'm gonna
keep messing that one angle key
stick with steve
carla serves up an early dinner we eat
our last supper and hugh bluntly asks
what the hell are you going to do back
in that [ __ ] hole
for a moment i sit there surprised
staring at him dumbfounded
it's payback time i quietly reply
payback for what
he looks surprised then it dawns on him
you dumbass
you aren't my babysitter my big brother
anymore i don't need you to fight any
battles on my behalf
i did my duty took my hits and now i'm
going to college it's time for me to
build my life
the government got there three years and
you can bet you're bippy that there's no
one in this country who gives a [ __ ]
except those
who went there and did it sometimes i'm
not sure
most of them care either time to move on
brother
time to move on grab me one of those
beers out of the cooler will you you
stupid idiot
and here's len's thoughts on that now
that announcement certainly shoots the
[ __ ] out of my public reason for going
back
i've been telling everyone who asked
that i'm going to extract a little hide
from the charlies
who nailed my little brother now he's
telling me he's not my little brother
and to grow up well crap why the hell
didn't he make that speech before i
re-enlisted
laughing to myself i'm a green beret
i'm going to be a recon man that's why
i'm going back i want to find out what
it's like
to be the best at something
fast forward denying safe house 22 the
three of us
anxiously await a top secret briefing in
a small
secured out building that once was a
carriage house
a sergeant first class e7 is standing
behind a long
wide thick plank table behind him a
captain wearing the green beret and a
starched uniform sits quietly watching
with an offhanded relaxed gesture so
typical of sf men
the e7 motions to us to sit
rising from his chair the captain says
during your training at bragg you
men were selected as potential
candidates for military assistance
command vietnam studies and observations
group
studies and observations what the hell
is that god damn it i came back to be a
recon man
sounds like they're going to make us
into a bunch of clerks i will give you a
series of
briefings the first of which requires
you to make a decision as to whether you
want to go on with the second
before we continue what you are about to
hear is classified top secret requiring
you to sign the non-disclosure form
in front of you read the form if you
choose not to sign get up and leave the
room
no questions asked read the form
okay sign the form and give it to the e7
this better not be a clerk's job
top secret clerk i read the form and
scribble my signature at the bottom
handing it to the e7
as he circulates among us
i know this is a lot of it and he goes
through some history that's
that's what's uh part of the briefing is
he says this four years ago april 1964
the government of south vietnam created
this special exploitation service or
ses to replace the vn special forces
command
concurrently the cia transferred its
advisory role to the newly formed
military assistance command vietnam
studies and observations group or mac v
sag which is run by the u.s military
joint services
last year the south vietnamese renamed
the ses
the strategic technical directorate
clearing his throat the captain picks up
a glass of water taking a long drink
and why do i need to know all this
questions no okay to the point
you men will be assigned to an fob
forward operations base or fobs
have been in existence since 1964. they
are located in fubai kaisan
kamduk and da nang
fobs conduct classified operations
outside south vietnam
classified operations doesn't sound like
a clerk's job to me
this is getting interesting
operations in the laos commenced
september 1965
as part of operation shining brass and
recently
have been renamed prairie fire
out of country operations are conducted
by recon teams
called spike teams hatchet forces and
slam companies
break those down for us real quick spike
teams hatchet forces
and and and there's also like rt
which is recon team well in the early
days up until the end of 68 it was spike
team
because it was top secret code for recon
team
got it and then you had the hatchet
force which could be anything for a
platoon
up to a company size operation like
operation tailwind
and then the slam operations that would
be one or two hatchet force components
depending
on the size they would go in and block
the ho chi minh trail
back it up and then the air force would
have air power
so anything that backed up on the trail
they would hit it hit it hard
and of course the nva responded very
quickly and the elements that were on
the ground
got hammered so slam got slammed with
those operations
that's why by the time you get the
tailwind in 70 they change the mo
a little bit but that's the breakdown
got it yeah
uh this this captain continues on mac
visa
v mac v sag is a joint service
high command unconventional warfare task
force whose charters to conduct
top secret sabotage psychological and
special operations
in north and south vietnam laos cambodia
and southern china it has been given
the title studies and observation group
as a cover the joint staff is allegedly
performing an analysis of the lessons
learned
up to this point in the war it's
obviously a special
operations group macv sog is organized
into two field commands command and
control south and north
also called ccs and ccn
i know this is a lot of material and i'm
jumping ahead i know this is a lot of
material but
we want you to know what you're
volunteering for
to continue and he keeps the throughout
this and lynn doesn't
actually lin says this i volunteered to
be here i volunteered
for recon sounds like i'm getting
exactly what i asked for
how old is lin at this point it's nice
75 no
at this point oh there um he must be
young because he didn't do oh no he did
a deployment with the oh yeah no he's
he's older actually
yeah he's actually probably older than
you how old are you probably i was 22
i think lynn would have been he's a year
ahead of me okay yeah
like he's 75 now i'm four there you go
um but still damn that's young
but you know why i was the reason i ask
you that is because when i think about
what a young
american male mind
is like it's like this you're sitting
here and you
there's nothing more that anyone wants
to hear than
a joint service high command
unconventional warfare task force who
charters to conduct
top secret sabotage psychological and
special operations
sign me up here we go airborne
uh continuing on macv's mission is
twofold support south vietnam against
communist aggression
assist in the development of the
southern republic the united states and
our allies will succeed by winning the
people depriving the enemy of safe
havens rests and supplies depriving the
enemy
and this is where mack vsog comes into
the picture
sog has five primary responsibilities
and the capability to undertake
additional special missions
as required listen up songs primary
responsibilities include
first cross-border operations conducted
to disrupt khmer rouge
put that pathetic path at lao
and nva in their own territories
so that's cambodia laos and and
and v and north vietnam
secondly keep track of all the
imprisoned and missing americans
and conducting raids to assist and free
them as part of the escape invasion
mission for all captured u.s ground
personnel and downed airmen
mission 3 is training and dispatching
agents into north vietnam to run
resistance operations called black
psychological operations such as
establishing false national nva
broadcasting stations inside north
vietnam
and yellow cyclop psychological
operations as typified
by the hue the way citadel propaganda
transmitter
mentioned earlier four the captain holds
up four fingers waving then
them at us mack v sog is also entrusted
with specific tasks such as kidnapping
assassination and insertion of rigged
mortar rounds into enemy
ammunition supply system which are set
to explode and destroy their crews upon
use
he pauses to study our faces again
clearing his throat
five he coughs again is the retrieval of
sensitive documents and equipment if
lost or captured
through enemy action he pauses any
questions
silence in the room
lynn thinks to himself this is a hell of
a lot more than just recon
[Laughter]
wow
the next level of information reveals
daily operational details i will show
you out of the country
areas of operations talk in detail about
the team makeup
and the commitment we hope you will
volunteer to make any of you who want to
bail
out now is the time he pauses looking
around the room
looks like we're all in this is going to
be a hell of a lot of fun
reaching to his left the captain rolls
back a black cloth
covering a map of southeast asia mac v
sog is a top secret organization
operating the width and breadth of the
dmz west into laos
and south down through cambodia the
shaded areas you see delineate the ao
our area of operations you will enter
the ao with no personal identification
your weapons will not contain serial
numbers you and your gear
will be what we call sterile you will
carry nothing that identifies you as an
american
you will not carry pictures of your
loved ones or anything else that doesn't
directly pertain to your mission
occasionally you will use enemy weapons
as well and dress like them
he pauses are there any questions he
picks up a glass of water
are there any questions the captain asks
the second times
the second time receiving no response
other than stunned faces he continues
accepting this assignments accepting
this assignment
means you will be expected to run a
minimum of three
cross-border missions to complete your
tour of duty with sog
after those missions you can request a
change of assignment to finish out your
year
in country if you wish to leave sog
we will honor that request if you wish
to leave special forces
we will send you to another unit or you
can stay and continue running missions
now are there any questions
yes sir are we spies
ask one of our party without hesitation
by
international law yes this is a covert
operation as i said
top secret our job is to trail watch
pow snatch wiretap ambush and just plain
old enemy
interdiction you will be assigned to
recon teams rts
those teams are led by three americans
who are supported by nine mercenary
commandos
which make up a full 12-man team the
american leader is designated a 1-0
the assistant team leader is a 1-1 and
finally the radio operator
has a designation of one two the
mercenaries are paid by us to work in
the ao you see on this map
additionally there might be an arvind
special forces team member
whose job it is to handle the mercenary
mercenaries
while you do your intelligence work
e7 next form please please read this
carefully before accepting or rejecting
it
if you sign you will become members of
the most elite fighting force the united
states has ever put in the field against
an enemy
we are fighting a secret war as i said
earlier
you can never divulge your participation
recognize or give koreans to
any second or third party knowledge of
our existence
the captain and e7 move into a shadowed
corner quietly talking
i read carefully through the
non-disclosure statements
threats of imprisonment disgrace loss of
rights and freedoms
i sign talk about getting what you ask
for
the e7 distributes another set of papers
to each of us
gentlemen welcome to mac v sog smiles
the captain
we now need to address this last little
consideration
if you're unlucky enough to be captured
and wind up as a pow
we have a cover story along with an
individual recognition procedure don't
share what you are about to write
with anyone there are questions on this
form
they are the same questions for each of
you however your response will be
individual
and will become the key to recognizing
you and obtaining your release as a pow
please fill in the answers
make them simple and conversational put
the form into the attached manila
envelope and seal it
hand the envelope to me and no one else
in this room
do not look at each other's answers
collecting the envelopes and stuffing
them into a canvas attache the captain
says
men thank you for volunteering good luck
and goodbye
yeah i forgot that part about the uh the
last the second document
you put your individual information down
i forgot about that lin
being sharper as he is he must have
taken notes
he's got some incredible information man
welcome to the secret war welcome to sog
yes indeed
did you did you when you were going
through that moment did you have any
like
hesitation oh you just so all in it was
ridiculous
ridiculous yeah absolutely just like
lynn i mean you know
in my case we had been going through all
our training for all those months
and it's like this is this is the war
and like you know
the green beret movie had been out what
would the duke do
yeah and what's crazy is you were told
you were told don't volunteer for sog oh
yeah we went through training group
they're like hey listen
yeah don't volunteer for soccer whatever
you do don't volunteer for sog well even
there
it wasn't like direct it would be like
you know when you go get to an a camp
learn about the country to people
and there's projects don't volunteer get
because those people are dying
and this is 68 we had so many teams have
been wiped out by that point
the briefer didn't tell lynn anything
about that
the casualty race by that point oh yeah
gearing up each individual will wear or
carry sterile fatigue
or tiger suit flop brim hat with a
portion of panel sewn inside
the top jungle boots pistol belt
harness first aid packet pill kit heavy
and sharp canteens with water
purification tablets
smoke grenades compass survival kit
individual pistol
submachine gun and sawed-off m79 weapons
signal mirror panel
strobe light pen flare with flares ammo
pouches rucksack with reinforced straps
rations weapons cleaning kit maps poncho
and liner
can opener p-38 or knife with can opener
waterproof matches
insect and leech repellent jungle
sweater rt10 survival radio pen light
six foot of nylon cord parachute
suspension cord
swiss seat two snap links notebook and
pencil two plastic bags fragmentation
white phosphorous and gas grenades
two cravat bandages gloves claymore
serum
the team will need to carry a camera and
film
binoculars a nprc
25 radio or as you call it a prick 25
with extra battery m14 tow popper mines
and booby traps anti-intrusion device
wire taps and equipment for prisoner
snatches
that's all what exactly is a wire
tap it's like
a go ahead tilt you'd have the telephone
lines right so that's the wire
and you tap into it and then in our case
you got the telephone pole put the wires
our wires onto their wire tape it
then come down the pole cover with mud
so if anybody walked by they wouldn't
see it and we'd have it tied into a
st at that time state-of-the-art
cassette before
yeah and we would record even if there
was nobody talking the cia had us
do the actual recordings so that um
they could hear it they would amplify
the tapes they could they said they
amplified 100 times they could hear
things in the background because
the nva phones when they're in the
cradle they're live
like our phones they're they they shut
off those are still alive and the ca
would
we give them all our tapes and they
would amplify it they said they got into
all of those things
yeah so they hear people talking in the
background about your stuff
yeah and of course you know cia we we
give they take
and they're done you never hear anything
back at all so when you say you're
you wiretap's part of the list of stuff
that you guys have what is it like a
little
apparatus or something it was the actual
cassette recorder
then the wire and then at the end of the
wire to be two little things that you
tape onto it
or do or go through sometimes a wire
you have like a double area yeah yeah
plug it in between yeah and then you
tape it
huh how big was the cassette recorder
shoebox i'm picturing shoebox
was as big as the shoebox no no no no
like this side size of a book yeah like
a book size like a duck book oh yeah
like the old school
very old yeah was it was it
was there tape cassettes in there or was
it like some kind of real to real
no kidding you guys were high-speed
brother this is 1968 not every real
stuff in the field
oh yeah dang and the cassettes you know
i think we had
by then they had the two-hour cassette
so you could do an hour on each and one
side
as opposed to a 60 with 30 on each side
and someone's sitting down there
freaking flipping those damn cassettes
over
while you're out in laos in cambodia hey
it keeps you something to divert your
attention from
watching the trail yeah swatting
mosquitoes
so i mentioned that the way he sets this
book up is you're reading and it makes
it very conversational in a way
but he sets a lot of it up as debriefing
yeah
and and he also wrote this and this is
one of his thoughts have you ever seen
yourself through the eyes of someone
you've become
no this isn't an existential existential
question
really have you and what that made me
think about is
when you're debriefing you're kind of
you're kind of forcing yourself to
detach and explain what you did and it's
almost like you're seeing yourself
yeah in a in a in a third person
situation um so
in this particular set to set this up
they're in there
and this isn't we we talked a little bit
about you guys playing liar's dice and
sitting around the bar and
having some drinks and debriefing
amongst yourselves
well this one is set up not like that
this is an official debriefing
oh yeah and did you guys always do
official debriefings because it doesn't
sound like it sounds like this was a
an operation that was so significant
that it required a
like a like an on-site special
debriefing oh yeah always we went right
to s2
oh okay so you guys always did this aar
so that's an sop
got it absolutely and it was really hot
they would get the initial word down
by radio transmission on rtt and then
come back with a four after action
report
yeah it sounds like this one is um
pretty significant so
and and i'm gonna fast forward just a
little bit
and here we go specialist black
please begin which again this is crazy
he's an e4
yeah freaking crazy
specialist black please pre please begin
apprehensively i mentally moved back in
time
the monthly saigon target list arrived
and as usual the team leaders
gathered in the tactical operations
center to pick or be assigned their
missions
some have to be assigned because no one
wants to run those targets
why is that they're known to be one-way
trips
i see response the sergeant oscar 8
which is known to be one of those
one-way trips is always assigned on a
lottery system
my understanding is that the last 12
teams attempting to run that mission
have never been heard from again
or or were so shot up that they've been
disbanded
so this one particular mission set was
called oscar 8
and this oscar 8 there's been 12 teams
that have gone to
execute this operation and they've
either totally disappeared or they've
been so
so messed up that they disbanded the
teams oh yeah
it's just the nasty targets where the
major roads came together i forget the
exact highways like
92 there's a couple other all came in
the northern part of south vietnam
and we later learned they had a major
headquarters area there
and that's where like on the ground the
first book with pat
first chapter with pat watkins they were
in oscar eight when the nva came up and
said it's your turn for guard duty
that's what lynn's talking about
he says uh here one of them one of them
one of the analysts
specialist black we're interested in the
intel gathered during the vr
we know the history of the target chai
is the lieutenant
analyst so the guy's basically going
look we know it's a bad target we want
to know about your visual reconnaissance
sir
that's br and he's showing a lot of
restraint right now
sir that's precisely the point i'm
getting at please bear with me as i step
through this process so i don't forget
any of the details keep calm man he
doesn't have a clue of the edge i'm
teetering on
calm down got to get calmed down how
long does it take to get over the after
mission jitters
be quick about it specialist replies the
lieutenant impatiently
yeah a ramp at that
yes sir alabama won the lottery
r11 i point to angelkey
ankle key angle key i put to angle key
volunteered to lead us through a map
study picking primary secondary
and alternate landing zones landing in
extraction zones we studied every bit of
intelligence we could lay our hands on
about
the weather patterns in the ao area of
operation the known enemy
and how they maneuver sometimes you can
pick up more information in the club
than in the reports not in this case
there are no surviving old hands to talk
about the lottery
there was no intel in the target folder
that's the point sir
so they're going in blind no turnover
and then he then fast forward a little
bit the the analyst
says you were provided no target
intelligence we were told none was
available
armed with maps and a camera bulldog
scheduled a vr
two days before mission launch offers
one one
bulldog whose code name is that it was
the code name of sergeant stride
the alabama team leader r10
as you know he was greased uh killed in
action
like one one said the same person
sitting next to you the same one one
are you referring to specialist angle
key yes sir
recon team alabama's one one
the assistant team leader like he said
he was sick so i ran the vr with bulldog
we needed the intel to be as fresh as
possible for the mission it takes one
day to develop film
and study the pictures so it was never
it was then or never if we were going to
launch on october 5th
one one wasn't feeling well that made me
the photographer
bulldog and i squeezed side by side into
the narrow rear seat
of a vietnamese air force u-17 the
weather was clear
we took off from fubai airfield circling
out over the china sea we came in high
taking pictures of the entire ao yelling
at each other
over the engine noise in order to
discuss what we could see and attempting
to orient what we saw
to the maps with those windows and this
is a thought
with those windows open and the maps
were blowing all over the damn place
until bulldog got them under control
we flew under clouds and over rivers of
mist
filled ridges plateaus and valleys
picking a primary
and two alternate lz's
bulldog ordered the pilot to make a
photo pass over the primary lz at 100
feet the pilot objected
and told us he wanted to stay high and
leave the area soon good thinking
replies the sergeant
bulldogs slapped the pilot on the back
of his head so this is him this is
i'm not doing this very well but this is
this is lynn black kind of explaining
hey bulldog ordered the
pilots make another to to make another
pass and
the pilot said no i'm not going to do it
and then the sergeant says
good thinking and he says well bulldogs
slapped the pile on the back of his
helmet barking the order again
we dropped down to teardrop to treetop
level
and i managed one picture before the
nose the ship rose and we began banking
for another pass
as we climbed our plane was stitched
with machine gun fire
rounds ripped through the floor exited
the ceiling the cabin was sprayed and
flecked with blood as the co-pilot was
struck under the chin his helmet slammed
against the ceiling
ricocheting into my lap still containing
part of his head
that picture will be imprinted in my
mind forever
forever and he says
he he thinks it's a it's a pain i guess
i'm sad
sadness that grips the soul of my very
being i like that co-pilot
before we took off from fuba he was
trying to tell me a joke in really bad
english
i didn't get it but laughed anyways
you're okay specialist black
yo are you sorry you okay specialist
blast black asked
chief sog glancing at his medical team
yes sir i was telling you about the
incident
the image of the helmet and partial head
popped into my
mind i'd never seen anything like that
before
i was fighting a thousand emotions all
at once all flooding through me forcing
my eyes to glisten
those kind of images have a way of
staying with us for the reminder of our
lives
each of us has to find a way to deal
with them in order to go on
continue with your story orders the
chief patiently
yes sir i collect my thoughts the pilot
dropped the cessna
back down to treetop level we got the
hell out of dodge and the wild west
yeah you know you you mentioned ramps
you know you said that this lieutenant
alanis is a rampant for those people
that don't know remf is
stands for rear echelon [ __ ] and
that's the person that's
these are the people that are not on the
front lines not doing the fighting it's
actually the genesis of the name of my
consulting company
echelon front which is not rear echelon
hey i'm in the rear with the gear but
hey frontline leadership and and this
whole scene you know for whatever
hollywood director is listening to this
right now or whatever producer
who makes movies echo charles oh all of
those people whoever's gonna make this
into a movie
this is the iconic scene
of the rear echelon [ __ ]
trying to debrief this guy and we're
going to get into the mission and once
you
once you realize what he just went
through you can see
why this is such an intense scene
because he's sitting there
just having barely survived lost
guys and they're asking him these
questions and it's just your classic
iconic scene of a disconnect between the
people on the front lines
and the rear echelon [ __ ] and
that's october 3rd two days before the
actual mission
doing a vr oh yeah oh yeah that's right
so yes so the debrief is after the
mission but the part that he's talking
about
they haven't even done the mission yet
yeah this is they're getting shot at as
they're doing a visual reconnaissance
they lose a pilot
while they're doing the visual
reconnaissance can you imagine
this is why this is till if you did this
vr
and you came back to me and said hey
jocko we did the visual reconnaissance
by the way we had a pilot shot the plane
got shot up
i got a used helmet if you want to use
it yeah i'd say hey guess what we're not
going into there
i think i'd say well it's not happening
okay
it's not we're not go it's a no-go yeah
you guys had freaking balls
we didn't have you yeah
crazy the insertion covey
was captain greg hartness covey 265 was
his call sign
his rider was sergeant first class
patrick watkins code knight code named
mandolin the second covey pilot was
colonel
don borncassel and his rider was staff
sergeant bob parks his code name
is spider lieutenant george miller
scarface 56 was the lead gunship pilot
who escorted the king bees into the
insertion
so now we're now we're actually getting
into the operation
yes sir and they do you know i'm
skipping forward
you know and look as i said before
to get the rest of the details just buy
the book and read it and it's
it's it's an incredible the the details
that he captures
are are awesome so but i'm going to fast
forward a little bit
so um the he covers the insertions
and then the lieutenant says
that the the analyst lieutenant says we
expect you to take as long as you need
on this portion of the debrief
when you're finished i'm sure your 1-1
will fill any missing details
gather your thoughts and begin when
ready
1-1 fill in the details never mind that
back across the fence we're moving
through dense foliage a ridge rising to
a right
okay here goes
rt alabama was ambushed at approximately
0
800 hours on october 5th 1968
at coordinates yankee charlie five six
one
six niner two our point man hoa
was hit multiple times in his chest and
lower body
in that same instant three rounds
penetrated our 1-0
team leader's head cowboy the
interpreter
was behind stride and took an rpd round
below his left shoulder
i was behind cowboy when he went down
the assistant team leader the 1-1 went
down at the same time
i thought he was hit as well
are you hit i yell at the 1-1 receiving
no response
damn he's dead too only six of us left
standing
bring out the bodies engage the enemy
lock hua the zero one vietnamese team
leader
orders the recon team alabama to a to
fire a full magazine just off the ground
level to suppress enemy fire
at our right on a slight rise there's a
line of nva
firing down into our position they're
above us to the right over there i yell
over the din of the ambush
thumbing the selector of my car 15 to
single shot i began picking them off one
at a time
20 rounds expended i pushed the magazine
extraction button on the receiver
shredding vegetation royals in the air
punctuated by green nva tracers
searching out their targets fumbling for
another magazine and a canteen pouch on
my web gear
i peer through the raging flora storm in
the direction of the tracer source
an nva i shot a moment ago is getting up
and pointing in my direction
okay second magazine snaps into place
slapping the left side of the receiver
the car 15 bolt slams home
as i raised the weapon firing twice
stayed down damn it
we gotta break contact i yell at the
team continuing down the line emptying
magazine
two the nva fall like targets in a
shooting gallery
another line moves in behind them taking
their place wearing a low spot
we have to get out of this hole i yell
cowboy interprets to the team
who's cowboy is he an american
interpreter queries the puzzle
lieutenant analyst as he searches
through his notes
huh what did you ask sir cowboy who's
cowboy
cowboy is our vietnamese interpreter uh
doan van kahn
1-1 inserts quick quickly continue order
orders lieutenant crouching i reload
surveying our situation then grab the
radio handset off my web harness
covey blackjack we have three killed and
two wounded over
who's down covey rider patrick watkins
calmly demands
point bulldog in 1-1 over blackjack
you're not a doctor nor for that fact a
medic
you can't determine who's dead or alive
you must attempt to bring out all the
bodies for very
verification of death a fresh swarm of
automatic weapon fire
up another foliage hurricane drowning
out covey communication finally it
settles down
mandolin blackjack we're taking heavy
automatic fire
we'll be lucky to get the living out
they have us surrounded on three sides
and are firing down
into our position i'm moving the team
out of this hole
over chu hoy translated
means surrender yells one of the nva in
a short lull of the ambush
i don't think so i yell back firing in
his general direction
alabama's weapons on full auto drown out
further
chew hoy requests one one is alive
and praying in the middle of a fire in
the middle of a gun fight this is no
time to pray get up off your sorry ass
and return
fire i yell one one looks at me with
dough eyes shifting his body in an
attempt to make him
make his form smaller i kneel down next
to him and find he has a catholic rosary
pressed to his lips
and is quietly chanting a prayer i need
you to take
tactical command while i do my job
directing airstrikes and get us a ride
home
i don't know what to do i i can't think
i can't
angle key slips into himself well
whiskey tango foxtrot over
leaves and twigs rain down on alabama
as the ground erupts around us from
automatic weapons fire
so his 1-1 is locked up mentally at this
point gone
body there but no mind no courage and he
actually thought he was dead
when everyone got shot in that opening
ambush lin
which by the way his nickname his code
name is blackjack so that's
that's who it is blackjack thinks he's
dead
but then he finally gets to him and
looks at him and he's not even
shot but he's he's having he's having a
meltdown
he's on his rosaries
back on the radio mandolin so mandolin
is the call sign of the uh covey
mandolin blackjack you're right we don't
have three dead we only have two
one one is alive the nva are now on all
sides with snipers climbing into trees i
have to take action quickly
or die blackjack put your 1-1 on the
horn over
so here's here's the covey rider saying
hey put your
put the guy in charge on the radio i
attempt to push the radio handset into
one one's hands but he wraps both hands
around his rosary
chanting he drops his head drawing
his form further inward
cowboy tell the team i'm the one zero
and locks and locks in charge of
b team as if i had to tell them lok's
already doing the job mandolin blackjack
one one is unable to talk right at the
moment i'm the one zero of alabama
stand by he's just freaking taken over
blackjack's ready to go oh yeah
no hesitation whatsoever none
roger replies mandolin cowboy
i have two have two men strip the bodies
get all weapons ammunitions masks
maps anything the nva can use distribute
their gear to the team quickly now
cowboy interprets as the two immediately
go to work on the bodies while the rest
of the
rest continue returning fire cowboy come
with me
tell loki's in command until we get back
i give loca
thumbs up as the two of us slowly crawl
advancing on hands and knees towards a
cluster of bushes
flicking aside a large black beetle as
has to not crush it
is that funny we're able to move close
enough to the nva that cowboy hears
their commander yelled as troops prepare
to charge their position
at the periphery of my vision sits a
small bird staring sitting below the
normal
human level of observation in an instant
in a flicker of wings it vanishes into
the undergrowth
i wish i could do that must have been
after the beetle everybody seems to be
after somebody
a kind-hearted reverence for life pushes
its way into my thoughts get the
claymore out of cowboys rock blasting
cap from the survival vest
that's it cowboy finishes out a hand
grenade
and wire spool hastily we rigged the
claymore in the direction of those
willing men from the north
the loving husband and the son-in-law
who likes to grow his own vegetables
[ __ ] them all a cloud of shredded
foliage rains down on cowboy and me
as we work our way back towards alabama
laying
the detonation wires get out of the line
of fire my little friend i whisper after
the bird
the insistent husbands brothers and
son-in-laws stampede towards our
indefensible position with weapons
blazing with their bulging veins
frothing at the mouth
the whites of their eyes wide cowboy
detonates the claymore
the air is filled with animal-like howls
gunfire
the smell of cordite rotting vegetation
and death
we have blown a bloody path right down
through the middle of them
claymore smokes clearing i yell alabama
up
follow me the team moves through the
path of carnage with our weapons on full
auto as we assist the wounded
online this is what you get for screwing
one of the with one of the black
brothers
what's left of their ragged line
sporadically fires into our small band
cowboy stumbles
and falls having taken another round in
his left side he comes haltingly to his
feet gives the
giving the okay signal once seemingly
through the past
nva battle line one seemingly through
and past the nva battle line
lok collap collapses our our online
formation
to inline and orders the team to go in
on
single shot the left of cowboy shirt is
soaked with blood blocked by impassable
terrain on one side and nva forces on
the other we work our way through the
dense undergrowth
back toward our point of insertion to
our rear
and in parallel on both flanks we can
hear the nva regrouping
gathering their strength random enemy
shooting subsides as they begin firing
signal shots to indicate the path of our
travel
flanking teams of two trackers for each
enemy squad intermittently push us along
as they reveal themselves we cut them
down with single shots
fire discipline is good gotta find a
place where we can stop to patch up our
wounded
don't fire randomly kill the enemy low
quarters
we continue maneuvering on our way
through the high thick
underbrush toward the primary lz leaving
behind the stripe the stripped bodies of
our point man
hoa and our 1-0 gym stride
oh i know can you imagine i mean just
how any of them lived
yeah it's amazing to see too
i mean just the just to see someone
step up both both blackjack
and cowboy cowboy is getting shot he's
wounded
and he's just leading and and lynn's
stepping up and leading when all this
mayhem is taking and
and you know i always say leadership is
the most important thing on the
battlefield right
if these guys didn't step up and lead
everyone's dead 100
it's a guarantee these guys step up they
take action
they lead and at this point
they're gonna it looks like they're
gonna get some progress yeah his zero
one was sharp and fearless
because he he rallied them took care of
the other details well then and cowboy
going on
and poor cowboy getting hit second time
like that
oh my god he's he was a big vietnamese
he was tall
cowboy cowboy he was the interpreter the
zero one
i forget his name you mentioned it there
i i just
zero one that's our vietnamese
counterpoint the 1-0 the american
0-1 he's had the experience because uh
alabama four months earlier the entire
team was wiped out as separate of 1-0
and he escaped and did a personal e e
back to the asheville valley and they
picked him up so
68 was a bad year for alabama but the
zero one did not go on that fateful
mission so they had his experience for
october the fifth that
between him and cowboy oh yeah loke
yeah that's who we're talking about loke
is the zero zero one
and then the other guy on there is dhoti
kwang
who later became the idol i stole him
from alabama a couple years later
he was great but just a fearless
absolute warrior
badasses oh yeah true and true yeah
i mean what's crazy is you know um that
you said was the
the bombers in in europe the bombers in
europe the american bombers that bombed
europe in world war ii
i think they had to do 25 missions if
they did 25 missions they were done
and sometimes they'd push a little
further yeah but yeah that was what the
rule
place was and the rule that they gave
you guys was three
i mean those bombers those guys were
taking
mass casualties mass casualties oh
absolutely
profound casualties and yet they said
hey you guys are going to do 25 missions
and you guys they're saying hey listen
can you can we get three out of you yeah
see now we never i don't remember that
part of the debrief if we ever had it
see lynn remembers those details that's
why his stuff is just
so great it's vivid yeah and don't
forget they taught the bombers they
remember the frenchman his dad was the
leader
right on this on one squadron 23 only
one comes back
out of a thousand airplanes so yeah the
same
uh catastrophic effects by the enemy
continuing on october 5th blackjack
mandolin
we're returning with the king bees to
fubai for fuel
no extraction is possible for at least
two maybe three hours
over another covey is
covey is on station you'll be talking to
spider
as fast as possible mandolin we're about
to
find out how much longer we can hold out
don't panic blackjack find the path
don't let them pin you down
spider spider bob parks x10 of rt idaho
just like mandolin spider blackjack over
blackjack spider keeping your cool buddy
keeping your cool buddy
he's there we're not alone man having
you guys
with that direct relationship oh yeah
with your cubbies and they sat in the
briefs and they knew what you were gonna
do
that's a powerful thing that was the key
having that rider and that's the epitome
of it that moment in time right there
because lin's like oh
watkins is gone the king bees are gone
nobody's gonna come back for two or
three hours
you be cool there's a spider talking to
him the night before he's beating his
ass on liar's dice at the clubhouse
i don't know if you've ever heard this
story but dave burke good deal david
yeah
he was in ramadi and he's anglico
supporting i think he's supporting an
army unit and it's the first
real close air support that he's
actually calling and you know he's a
former f
or he's an f-18 pilot and it just so
happens
by coincidence and miracle and other
coincidence
that he keys up the mic and says this is
lightning six
and the guy that answers the guy that's
in the air about to
give ordinance for him is like one of
his buddies no
and he says something like hey chip it's
you know hey chip it's maverick
um i'm ready to rock and roll he goes oh
it's like this so having that
relationship that you guys had with
these cubbies
man critical absolutely critical
uh so he says keeping your cool buddy
standby spider they're pushing us from
all sides
we're moving back towards the lz
perimeter and we'll be ready for
extraction over
grabbing a claymore from one of the
rucksacks i set up a 10 second fuse
pointing it to our rear
while lope covers me we can hear them
screaming in agony
as we move through the bush back towards
our
um insertion and you know what before we
go on
i just want to go back to this because
it's a it's a little bit of a point of
contention in the book
if you remember i read this part where
he says we continue maneuvering our way
through the high thick underbrush toward
the primary lz leaving behind the
stripped bodies of our point man hoa
and our 1-0 jim stride so
he had to make a decision the hardest
possible decision that a person could
have to make which is
hey these guys are dead we're going to
strip their bodies and we're going to
leave them
because if we try and and look anybody
that hasn't
ever carried a freaking another human
being through rough terrain
you have no idea you have no idea look
and you can say i'll pick up my
i'll pick up echo right now and i'll run
you know across the parking lot or
whatever
run a hundred yards yeah it's it might
not seem like that big of a deal
if you make echo actual dead weight
where he's not helping in any way not
adjusting his weight on you
not holding on to your neck or holding
onto your shoulders none of that
if it's just true dead weight 205 pounds
or 210 pounds or whatever
what are you 220 about 220. okay 220
pounds of dead weight
you're 185.
it's not that big of a deal to do it
it's not when you pick up a buddy and
you carry them across
the field the football field or the
parking lot it's not that big of a deal
when their dead weight is totally
different when you're in terrain
it's even more different and then when
you're getting freaking shot at
and assaulted by a massive number of nva
you got to make a decision what are we
gonna do are we gonna survive
or are we gonna perish to save our
friend's body
what would i want what would what would
if i was shot if i was dead what would i
want you to do
i'll die just bring my body out hell no
you get your ass out of there
and and so lynn had to make this
decision
and he made it quick and you know that's
how you survive oh yeah
it wasn't easy but he did the right
thing yeah um
that's the that's what you got to do and
it's not like and by the way
when you when you leave that body you're
not saying hell we're never going to do
anything no i
you go do a bright light you could do
what what you got to do once you get
your forces assembled and you can get
more guys and you can
get the right air cover and all that
stuff you're not abandoning them but at
that moment in time you got to make a
decision
to for the survivability of the team
just that's what you have to do
here's his thoughts wait a minute we
just marked our location how stupid was
that
this is after they blow after they blow
up a claymore they're like oh
that was a bad move we just marked our
location
evades stay out of contact as long as
possible yeah right the nva
know we're heading toward the lz and
they're trying to push us on to it
to where we'll be easier targets they
intend to use us
as bait so they can shoot down more
helicopters once we're dead
and the helicopters are down the line
wait for the bright light
rescue choppers screw that today it's
not gonna
today it's gonna end with us dead or
alive these bastards aren't gonna use me
as bait
bait maybe we can bait them out onto the
lz where our gun ships can get at them
hunt the hunters so those are just
these are lynn's thoughts those were lin
lin's thoughts quickly working through
cowboy
loke and i decided to turn back against
the nva
we employ fire and maneuver a team
firing while b
team is maneuvering searching destroying
and clearing a path old school cover
move
we turn we turn moving back through the
claymore swath
until we encounter a larger enemy force
online
searching us out down wait ready
fire red and dream cree red and green
tracers fill the air moving like rush
hour
traffic lights we are able to grease a
couple of platoon size forces
up on me alabama forms up as i point
southwest towards the lz
a new nva line is flooding in this
behind searching us out
they are using grenades to clear the
jungle as they move whistles
are sounding on two sides indicating we
are moving into a possible ambush
they're attempting to hurt us together
on the edge of the lz
where there's a two thousand foot shear
drop on the southern edge
alabama online yells loc pointing to
pointing our direction of travel boldly
we charge pushing them back mowing them
down like weeds
bold move we close to the perimeter to
the lz perimeter
don't let them force us out into the
open a fast moving object enters my
peripheral vision
whack my head is snapped back by a
wooden handled grenade
instantly i'm looking into the jungle
canopy seeing a muddled green
light stream through a haze of cordite
it's over
you saw it coming and couldn't get out
of the way lower
below me the concussion lifts me from
the ground pushing me through the air
my feet are over my head green tracers
track crack around me like lady finger
firecrackers
that tree is upside down and moving fast
this is all wrong
focus or you'll miss the moment of your
death i hear myself
say i can't breathe i feel like i'm
drowning the team
they are frantically beating me back to
consciousness pouring water over my head
okay okay i'm back
i try to get up my legs don't work
from the knees down my fatigue pants are
shredded and i'm bleeding
one of the men clang starts smearing
gelatinized rice on my legs arms face
and chest
web gear and what is left of my survival
vest are lying on the ground in a bloody
tatters along with the car 15. it's bent
where the barrel meets the receiver
and the bolt can't be pulled back loke
orders a scout to bury the car
cowboy hands me stride's weapon cowboy
what's wrong with your hand
grenade shrapnel he winces
handing me the weapon you have now
officially pissed me off i scream at the
nva
[Laughter]
so at this point they're they're doing
fire maneuver
they get to the edge of the lz he gets
hit in the head with a freaking grenade
and then it detonates blows him up in
the air
destroyed his car 15. destroyed his car
15.
yeah this is after they charge through
the nva rank
they go through them it's like even on
my best day i don't think i would have
thought of that
it had to be somebody like lynn it's
just such a distinct
yeah courageous movie it is and it's one
of those things where that's the last
thing that the enemies
thinks you're going to do and they
probably just it would look it was the
last thing they would think
yeah and then when it happens they're
not ready for it they're like wait a
second what's happening
it's a brilliant just a brilliant move
so he says you have now officially
pissed me off
i scream at the nva god damn my head
hurts when i do that scrabbling
around my position i finally find the
radio handset spider blackjack
i'm declaring a prairie fire emergency
a prairie fire emergency should drop
enough napalm on you suckers to ruin
your day
laughing blackjack says laughing
the reply comes blackjack no kidding
brother keep your cool
above all else keep your cool
so that's awesome i mean um spider had
already said hey this
he's already moving assets into place he
can tell that this is a [ __ ] sandwich
down here
and and then he gives us advice you know
this is advice we could all use
keep your cool above all else keep your
cool oh yeah
and that means so much because it's
coming from spider who's a
who's a a 1-0 himself that's been on the
ground that knows what's happening
and he's saying above all else keep you
cool
and so then he says to himself calm the
hell down blackjack
be cool so that actually worked he
actually listened
spider blackjack so what's our asset
status
over all assets have been diverted to
your location covey will coordinate them
as they arrive and let you know
what armament is available you make the
decision what you want
when and where you want it any questions
who's up first
i attempt to rise but fall flat on my
face god damn it
six gunships will prep the lz with gun
and rocket runs amongst
them will one will attempt to land if
that's not possible
it will trail a ladder improvise brother
roger spider
i roll over hugging the radio receiver
to my ear
trying to get to my feet the gunships
fire rockets and then make gun runs near
our position
the rescue ship attempts to land twice
twice we make our move
too much lead in the air ground fire is
much too intense
they're hammering our pickup to pieces
get it out of here
spider do you copy over the rescue ship
limps off while the while marine
scarface ships expend their ordinance in
covering fire
blackjack spider fubai is mounting a
bright light rescue
to assist you in the fight
that's kind of crazy because bruh i mean
bright light is as bad as it gets right
that means we either had people overrun
or had people captured
and they're already launching we're
getting ready
they talked about that's where because
we were scheduled for the next day and
that we were the bright lights oh so you
guys were the freaking bright light yeah
and they're telling so so what is that
like what are you hearing
it's like this is this is not going to
be a good day and you just don't know
can you hear what what the aircraft
cause i know you can't hear what the
guys on the ground are saying because
they're on the ground and they
it's not line of sight so you wouldn't
be able could you guys hear what the
aircraft are saying back to the guys on
the ground
when you guys work transmission and pat
watkins you could hear some of it
could depend on where they were how low
they were and up
so we picked up some we just knew it was
a [ __ ] show
because the whole camp this society
everybody just
came to a pause and started praying for
them and so what do you guys
so so are you the are you the one zero
no don welcome was the 1-0 back then i
was the 1-1 for idaho
and they talked about the bright light
don had gone in for the brief
and they said we might be the bright
light what's your
what are you doing when you're when you
might be the bright light you already
have all your mags they're all loaded
you're right we're ready for the night
the next day you just
well you just take anything out then
it's just all bullets and grenades
and extra bandages maybe a couple body
bags
and then we never even got to the launch
site
they cancelled it because the it's
between
the enemy the anti-aircraft and and then
the
weather because it started to cloud it
over and then all the
gun smoke the cordite and then the
clouds
they figured one more team when there
would be more casualties in the king be
like
like what lynn just described yeah the
first attempt to get him out just like
get out of here you if you want to live
themselves yeah
which you think about the mindset
of lynn black yeah your savior
is coming down to rescue you
and you say nope get out of here yeah
what an honorable move
beyond yeah yeah
he says uh so he says so so spider says
hey we're getting a bright light ready
for you
and then blackjack spider blackjack how
would they get in here
we don't need more people on the ground
or helicopters shot down
don't let the nva use us as bait we need
to get off the ground
and out of the line of fire in the
meantime what i really need is a
resupply of ammo
over blackjack you okay
i got nailed with a grenade nothing
serious over just can't walk
ammo is on the way and i agree with your
assessment of the bright light over
spider tel fubai alabama is not a
sacrificial lamb
no bright light over so not only do you
call off his
the helicopters from coming in he's
calling off the rescue mission himself
he's saying
hey don't send a bright light
i'm glad he said that
he says roger blackjack by the way the
assets are beginning to have difficulty
with the weather
and smoke hanging over the lz you're
difficult to spot which makes
accurate airstrikes increasingly
difficult over
cowboy is working on my legs while he's
telling me boku nva on lz
we can hear gunships overhead and
witness nva tracers riddling the lead
ship
the nva move across the grassy plain of
the lz
like a work party of ants trap tramping
down the two-foot razor grass
which is the only concealment we have
suddenly one one panics
shouting skyward god save us
the nva swarm migrates in our direction
so the one one who's been freaked out
this whole time and hasn't
done his job now yells out
god save us and the nva hear it
vietnamese team members speaking through
cowboys say we're going to kill 1-1 if
he doesn't shut up
i'll pull the trigger on him myself i
agree
tearfully one one whispers whimpers
god forgive you sounds of an approaching
can be
king b and our diversion as the carrots
of survival are dangled in front of us
again each king
kingby can hold four so we gotta get
everyone out on two
sure hope they brought a dozen to this
party we've meant
we've got to get to the center of the lv
help the wounded move i scream in one
one's face
fearfully confused one one takes hold of
loke
who is in the who brushes him off with
disdain
blackjack spider first kingby inbound
gunships begin prepping the lz with rack
rockets 40 mike mike and m60s blackjack
spider
i've got a fast mover on track key your
handset so he can get a lock
put your heads in the dirt over roger
roger spider handset keyed heads down
we look into the haze street sun as
a full flapped phantom his glide path
ratio critical ignites the tree line
across the lz into sheets of white
yellow and orange flames
the ship banks sharply after burners
crank on and he powers into the valley
below
nva small arms open up on three sides
lazy wagging tongue tongues of green
tracer fire sweep the sky for miles
heavy triple a fire chase the end the f4
jesus some of those guns aren't far from
our location
how many of these bastards are there
what the hell are we in the middle of
keying my handset spider blackjack did
you see that anti-aircraft fire on the
fast mover
over roger blackjack marking map
coordinates now
this is mandolin back on station over
so they've gone from spider as the covey
well from from mandolin to spider and
now we're back to mandolin
and by the way props to that the f4
phantom you know we had it we've we've
had a couple f4 phantom
vietnam pilots on here oh yeah those
guys were
those guys were doing a freaking doing
god's work up there especially in a case
like this drop a napalm
to save these guys
among those shooting are several nva
about 20 feet from our perimeter
napalm torches the jungle forcing dozens
of the enemy to scurry onto the lz
escaping the inferno engulfing their
comrades just as another
f4 rolls in for a gun run the nva
movement
move in close to us making every
possible attempt to avoid the firestorm
firing on single shot we begin to pick
them off as they stream out
of the fire drenched jungle
those close to us endeavor to suppress
our fire attempting to protect their
comrades
their friends fathers brothers uncles
that onion-eating son-in-law
as they pop up we put them down phantoms
return
with two cannon and gun runs along our
perimeter and i haven't really gone into
this but
you can hear a couple times that lin has
replied referred to the
enemy as fathers and sons and
and brothers and uncles and so he he
just does that to kind of
let you know what he's thinking about
and he's thinking like yeah these are
these are
other men and we're about to kill them
that's the way it goes
oh yeah
he yells out ammo check
and then two nine cylinder radial engine
king bees come
chugging up the valley toward us we
ignite green smoke marking our position
the nva
ignite identical smoke markers at
several locations
confusing the pilots god
oh yeah bastards it gets worse
we rise moving toward the approaching
ships killing everyone in our path
ammo is getting critical each of the
team has less than a full magazine
and those are 20 round mags god
whoever invented the 20 round mag
instead of the 30 round mag
the m79 men are down to their last
bandoliers i'm
stumbling along working with my browning
it's cord peeling the skin off the back
of my burned neck
we watch in disbelief as this first king
b touches down right over an nva smoke
marker
taking multiple rpg rocket round hits on
the flight deck so
just to clarify that so everyone can
understand when you're marking for
location to to get first of all you got
to understand that when you're in
um when you're in the sky when you're in
a helicopter
and you're looking down at the ground
it's freaking huge
it's massive and and i've i had a time
where
i was in a in a training operation and
there was a helicopter coming to pick us
up
and i was standing there and this was in
the desert
with your panel and i was standing there
with my panel and i'm waving it and i'm
like oh yeah i'm right here and he goes
where are you
and i said i'm right here and he says
where are you and i said i'm right
freaking here
and i'm on the hilltop or whatever
stupid thing i said because i was
a younger guy yeah i'm on the hilltop
well
i le i learned a lesson you know how
many hilltops he can see from his
helicopter you can see
500 of them so i don't narrow it down at
all
so what we do is we mark our position
with something that's very
obvious like green smoke so in this
situation
blackjack gets the green smoke out hey
come land on this green smoke
the the nva see that and they go oh
yep we know what that is they're marked
with green smoke hey pull out the green
smoke boom
so they start throwing green smoke so
now what does it look like there's green
smoke everywhere
additionally they were monitoring the
radio oh yeah
so they had rdf as well as the
monitoring capabilities
and so when they heard i don't think
lyndon would have said green he probably
were gonna pop a smoke
the nba either guest was a good guess
and you got the results coming
so here we go we watching dis belief as
the first king bee touches down
right over an nva smoke marker taking
multiple rpg rocket rounds
round hits on its flight deck the force
of the blast is so great the ship
teeters and finally topples to its side
each subsequent rotor blade smashing
into the ground
whoop whooping in our direction narrowly
missing
alabama as we approach we grab up nva
weapons
turning them on the enemy they're
everywhere why didn't we see them until
now
without hesitation we charge the rocket
position
killing several nva before a hail of
fire drives us back to our starting
point
these aks have a slower rate of cyclic
fire
cyclic fire the ammunition will last
longer we don't need a resupply we can
keep doing this till hell freezes over
the second so there they ran out of ammo
basically now they're picking up the
enemy ak-47s
and they're shooting and the ak is
definitely slower shooting
than uh than a car 15 the second ship
hits an outcropping of rock on the
western side of the knoll after taking
heavy gunfire
and falls onto the valley floor below
blackjack
mandolin nice try over screw you
mandolin
i no longer want to be extracted i'm
going to kill
every one of these sons of mothers
before this day ends
so there you go i'm going to read that
again i no longer want to be extracted
i'm going to kill every one of these
sons and mothers before this day ends
oh yeah lynn black
you don't want to piss off lin black no
no no no
[Laughter]
even on a good day then cowboy says
to that in response to that cowboy who's
again this is the interpreter
right he's the interpreter yes he says
one one
this is the one one the guy that's been
praying the whole time he says 1-1
please pray for the team except
blackjack he's on the devil's side now
blackjack mandolin fast movers have
expended their ordinance are
and are returning for resupply your ammo
was on that second king b
assets in 20 minutes good luck brother
mandolin blackjack
we don't need forget it over blackjack
mandolin blackjack mandolin what's your
status over
damn it blackjack bugles are sounding
wave upon wave of nva troops carrying
rifles with
fixed bayonets is advancing online
when they are feet away we open fire
using weapons we have taken from their
dead
after the first burst of full automatic
the team fumbles with ak-47 selector
switches to single shot
pushing them back we move from body to
body using their weapons and their
cadavers as shields
crawling kneeling knee walking standing
scrambling online in line
we defend each other and ourselves
without a word
a look a plan acting on training pure
survival instinct
all of us except one one are scampering
around
dragging lugging bodies placing them in
a circle around alabama
stacking them high we construct a
cadaver garrison
cowboy is bleeding from a grazing wound
to the back of his neck
tiny army green leeches in inch out of
the trampled razor grass
following the blood trails we've created
dragging the dead
focusing on details directly in front of
me i noticed the vampire mosquitoes and
ravenous
cannibalistic horseflies competing with
the leeches to feed on the dead and the
wounded and the on the living
one of the vietnamese flips me a plastic
mosquito repellent bottle
hey that stings what the hell are we
doing worrying about mosquitoes when
people are trying to kill us
snag us as much animal ammo as possible
i order
back and forth and again it's important
to remember that
this is this is lynn telling the story
he's debriefing and the way it's laid
out you can tell that he's debriefing in
the book i'm probably not doing a great
job but this is during the debrief
and what's interesting all these things
that he's saying about the one one
the one one is in the debrief with him
he's saying like oh he's not doing
anything and
and one one's in there and he just kind
of is and he goes into it a little bit
but he's kind of averting his eye he's
keeping his head down like you know he
he knows he didn't do a good job
back and forth between the nva and recon
team alabama continues the back and
forth between the nva
and the recon team alabama continues on
and on and on
they just keep coming i don't know how
much longer we can keep them up keep
this up
keep them off us the matted grass is
saturated with slimy slippery blood
and human innards smoke cordite and the
stench of death choke us
as foul weather closes in mosquitoes
horse flies and the enemy are
all conspiring to nibble us to death to
swallow us whole
soon air support will be possible slowly
i come to the realization that i have no
physical strength left and i can barely
move
i can't let my team down one of the team
slips and slides on his stomachs over
the cadaver garrison
to retrieve ammo while other members of
the team provide covering fire
so these guys are in a freaking small
little
fort that they've conduct that they've
constructed with enemy bodies
and when someone goes outside of that
perimeter they've constructed a little
perimeter
when someone goes outside that perimeter
from the team to go gather ammo the
other guys are laying down
fire to protect that guy yeah
you know here's another thing too with
that team they won zero they had another
1-0 on the team
prior to stride being assigned to it and
they worked really hard on their team
emergency action reaction drills and
what they're doing there i think some of
that goes back to the training
that 1-0 was tim schoff he really worked
the team hard
and it's a good 1-0 but stride for
reasons
known only to the command they pulled
tim off and put stride and target
because he had more rank
but that team right there that moment in
time when the team's doing all that
together
that's all that's training that they had
prior
and experience you know cowboy with his
years locke
and of course lin from the hurt
blackjack mandolin jolly green's 10
minutes out
get ready to go home over that
announcement lifts a thousand pounds
sandbag off my shoulders
we're going home mandolin blackjack do
you have any idea what size of the force
is over blackjack mandolin what you're
up against is the regiment you were sent
to track
over is that all only 3 000 of the
bastards
well i think we made it a dent i think
we made a dent in them don't you just
barely brother
bugle sound the sky is filled with
grenades
we're hugging the ground as if as they
explode around us and it's
till tell us a little bit about the fact
that the enemy
they don't have radios so what they use
is
whistles and bugles to coordinate their
attacks
yeah the command levels have some radios
and the command consider
to their commander like if you break it
down from platoon to squad leaders
and then with the bugles and the
commands that's what
they're they're trained how they are on
attack with withdrawal
and um that's what then came up against
over and over again yeah they uh in the
korean war
all those all those times when that
that's like the most horrifying thing
is all those times when they were to get
these human assault human wave assaults
towards their positions
it was all whistles they'd hear the
whistles and they'd hear the bugles
and they would know what was about to
happen sometimes it's for psyops just to
make the noise
every time you hurt you know they're
coming bugle sound
the sky is filled with grenades we're
hugging the ground as they explode
around us
hey these aren't fragmentation their
concussion just a bunch of noise
not sending out much shrapnel concussion
stuff stuff like the ones they used
on me earlier you're mine now you
bastards
you stand back up catching some
and begin throwing them immediately back
you should have seen the look on their
faces
oh crap here they come wooden grenade
shrapnel severs the prick 25 radio
antenna
i begin to rig an impromptu long wire
aerial with the intention of laying it
over the cliff behind us
out of harm's way relentless the nva
continue their advance alongside the
leeches mosquitoes and horse flies
inch by bloody inch chu hoy surrender
i yell at no one in particular mandolin
blackjack a large force is now yards
away from our perimeter
we need help two huey
hog attack helicopters rotor chopped
their way into the lz
first with the m60 chatter followed up
by the whoosh of rockets
placed into the nva ranks blackjack
judge over go judge
and the judge is one of the call signs
for for the marine corps
the marine corps uh this is the um the
muskets
oh okay judging the executioner okay
yeah so these are army units that came
out of america
and oh yeah scarfaces that scarface
marine corps are marine corps yes
so what kind of aircraft or is judge an
executioner same thing
oh so they're they're also cobras no not
no cobras at this time all the gunships
were old ues that could barely get off
the ground
got it in fact they're so weighted down
without and they're
they didn't have the power that the
later models had in fact a lot of times
when they took off the door gunners
would get out to try to lift the
helicopter and get it moving
and once they got a little forward
momentum they jump back in the
helicopter
and the muskets even put little wheels
on the front of the skids
so that when they're on asphalt they
would be able to move better without
having to skid bind
if they figured their wheel would roll
better and that good honestly out there
pushing these things
that's like fred flintstone situation
trying to get that right so
here's a sidebar on one of these on the
muskets
there was a guy his name was berg and
berry this was his very first
mission with with the muskets
on prairie fire for a sog mission
welcome to
psalms his first mission as a door
gunner
yeah these are two these are some epic
call signs though judge and executioner
oh yeah
so uh so judge checks in on the radio
and this is just such a you know as a
calm guy so when you get that aircraft
checking in it's like the best field in
the world and he comes up blackjack
judge over and the pilots are always a
little bit more
you know just sort of really smooth on
the radio and so he's coming in this
totally hot situation blackjack judge
over
and he says go judge anyone in
particular
or just kill them all he's laughing yeah
grease them all i say with malevolent
bloodied grimace
you're just in time for the party judges
door gunners are working their m-60s in
long bursts my guns are gone meltdown
executioner is right behind me
the nva back off a few moments briefly
licking their wounds far from
discouraged new assault lines form
before they can open fire on us
executioner confronts them head on
both door gunners blazing away he is
hovering inches off the lz
skipping rockets off the ground into
their ranks executioner lifts up
his rotors chopping loudly at the mist
filled air they make it over the tree
line ducking down into the basin below
remaining below anti-aircraft capability
regaining airspeed as they come up the
executioner and his crew returning for
another pass to protect our perimeter
the nva charge before we can celebrate
fire
fire we add more we add more of them to
the cadaver garrison
along with the weapons and much needed
ammo
silence no birds chirping no voices
mosquitos flies no sounds none
even the aircraft have flown far enough
away that their absence amplifies the
quiet
after an almost continuous melee of
gunfire grenades and claymore explosions
air ordnance expenditures including
cluster bomb units napalm and gun runs
and 20 millimeter cannons
silence have i gone deaf complete
silence you've been there
yeah that's freaking crazy yeah in dead
rest
each of us lays motionless and by the
way when you say i've been there
no tilt i have not been in a freaking
cadaver magazine yeah there's a little
mag change going on
uh each of us rests each in dead rest
each of us
lays motionless barely breathing my mind
is focused
inward unaware of its physical
surrounding mind and body are not one
one one continues to quietly chant his
prayer
cowboy has taken another hit during the
last skirmish along with two of the
others
come back think move summoning
energy from where i don't know i fumble
around in my medical gear
i'm giving you a morphine and we'll
apply a compress to that wound
we're going to run out of bandages if
you keep getting shot knock it off okay
so cowboy's been hit a couple times oh
more than that yeah it's like four or
five i lost count
and so yeah lynn tells me you're gonna
run out of bandages
so quick getting shot and then cowboy
says where's john wayne when you need
him
alabama laughs as the nva boisterously
yells
chu hoy dumas another nva
orders us to chew hoi in english i flip
him the bird as a sniper shoots
ku kwang our tail gunner in the crotch
i flip my borrowed ak on full auto and
unloaded into a tree about a hundred
yards away resulting in the sniper
falling through his limbs
through its limbs and brushed below to
the ground with a thud
if i could rip your heart out needed i
would kong
kwang what have we done last week you
got arrested by national police and way
in a way [ __ ] house for carrying a
pistol the entire
alabama team put on their gear and went
down and broke you out of jail so you
could go on this mission
god damn it i wish we'd left you in that
place where you'd be safe right now
lok i was calling him loke sorry lock
lock is applying direct
pressure to call to quang the tail
gunner's wound seconds later
an ae1 a1e skyraider lumbers into the ao
flown by a pilot codenamed snoopy
it roars in from the west brushing
treetops full
flaps working the throttle the aircraft
is so close to the team we can hear the
distinctive
metallic click click of the napalm
canister being released from the second
world war
era plane the skyraider appears to be
falling but
actually it slips down into the valley
to escape gunfire
as helicopters and fast movers have
maneuvered earlier
his wingman roils through the clouds and
cordite we can hear
nuts bolts and god knows what creaking
groaning as he saw
salvos his ships rockets three nva
mortars opened fire
boom boom boom they're long the rounds
fall into the valley at our rear
there's no way in hell any of us can
catch mortars and throw them back
time to go back to work i order
lock and i slide over the cadaver wall
crouching crawling knee walking we move
towards the mortars
cautiously picking our way through the
charred bodies from previous airborne
assaults
quietly yeah right we travel into the
jungle within a few yards of the forced
first mortar tube lock stops me to draw
a plant in the dirt
he will hit one two tube i will take
tube three and we will combine on tube
two
damn suicide mission i say under my
breath lock nods at me
keat roy he replies we die
after the mortar after the mortar men
launched the next set of three salvos
lock opens fire on his target while i
attack tube three discovering several
nearby infantry god so he's in the
middle of all this freaking crap and
then they're going out and assaulting
these three mortar positions
yeah which god knows i mean how far they
had to be at least 100 yards away
at least we're talking a football field
and there's just some spare infantry
trying to kill him in between
and those are some motivational words we
die and that's sort of like
[ __ ] it let's go yeah let's do this he
was a tiger
uh oh crap there are more of these
bastards than i thought
i begin moving low and fast as the
survivors chase me heading toward tube
one
where lock is pinned down yelling as
loud as possible drawing their attention
allowing locke to move out of the kill
zone
i roll our last fragmentation grenade
into their midst
killing several wounding the rest lock
and i attack the second tube before
returning to the team
picking ammo from the dead snipers dog
us all the way back to
our cadaver garrison the two of us press
our bloody bodies against the jungle
floor as green tracers
search the air around us 1-1 take a look
at this i say while rolling over
the blood and dirt on me are forming a
second skin
leaves and grasses have begun to stick
to my bare skin ants and beetles seem
to be making a home on my new crust i'm
building my own camouflage
it looks like i'm becoming part of this
place if i lay down i bet you they won't
tell me from the dead oh god please
don't go crazy you got to get us out of
here i want to go home he pleads
we'll all be dead long before i go crazy
through the clouds and haze of battle we
glimpse a jolly green
jg28 starting its descent into the lz
as it approaches the radio crackles
blackjack
this is 28 on short final looking for an
orange panel on the southeast side of
the lz
over
blackjack panel is on the ground we'll
attempt to suppress enemy fire for your
landing
orange panel in sight adjusting approach
preparing for touchdown blackjack
get your people on board over negative
negative not southeast we're southwest
you're in the wrong place get out of
there
the nva rays raise up all around jg28
firing everything they have
the pilot keys isn't radio to answer
back i hear a crew member in the
background
calm yelling we have fuel leak it's
everywhere get us out of here
we watch as the glass in the cockpit on
the co-pilot side disappears with
successive rocket explosions
the pilot struggles to lift while lift
off while maintaining control of his
ship 28 is up
28 is up our ride home is slipping
sideways across the lc
passing within touching distance above
us
over the lip of the plateau down into
the valley to escape the relentless
enemy barrage
alabama goes insane on full auto burning
up the majority of our ammo on anything
that moves
1-1 praise snoopy in his wingman move
into the next
move in next to the crippled jg28
through the haze and darkening storm
clouds covey is attempting to direct
gunships across the lz to pick off
targets of opportunity their rotors are
moving smoke and clouds down across our
cadaver strewn landscape
obscuring everyone's view 28 blackjack
28 blackjack are you guys okay
over blackjack we have a severed fuel
line
the stuff's sloshing all over the deck
fuel fumes are blinding my crew
we can't fire our guns without going up
in flames snoopy will escort us out of
here good luck blackjack out
oh yeah
tracers shift from horizontal grazing
fire across the lz
to vertical as jolly green giant 10
approaches
the green furies playing a deafening
tune through its skin
jg jg10 blackjack the enemy is under you
right now over from our position we can
see
an nva rocket crew rise up in the grass
take aim
and fire directly into the underbelly of
jg10
we're hit we have a six inch hole
through the floor both engine warning
lights just came on we can't make the
pickup
oh my god look at that both engines are
on fire the pilot performs a 180 degree
turn
moving the damaged aircraft away from
the enemy fire
away from alabama we can see him
struggling to keep his
bird airborne as his crew continues
firing
time has run out traveling several
hundred yards the pilot comes up on his
survival frequency brace for crash
landing
they continue firing while the burning
ship settles into the jungle
blackjack mandolin over go mandolin
first you won the lottery then you
maneuvered your way into a prairie fire
and now for the bonus round saigon has
ordered an arclight
over bonus round what do they think this
is the price is right there's no way we
can survive an arc light
tell it to the nva maybe they'll run
like hell and leave us be
what altitude will they be bombing from
they'll be cruising
at 25 000 feet for a standard carpet
bombing mission
not exactly accurate from that altitude
saigon is assuming you won't be there or
be alive by the time the b-52s
get here over damn straight i have to
get back to camp for recon company
football game this evening
how long do we have over
one of the indiges outside the garrison
stealing it stealing ak-47 magazines
from the dead he's tossing them into our
garrison
as the rest of us return fire blackjack
mandolin
the arclight is off the runway and
heading your way over so what
tell us about a tell us about an
arclight b-52 and what the
their load is like over 20 000 pounds of
bombs
and they usually come more than one and
you don't hear them
as you know you don't hear anything
until the first round impacts
and that's what that was the code for an
arc light and uh
amazing firepower and they're going to
basically carpet bomb
this area right that's the plan
what is carpet bomb bombs everywhere
everything like
just lay down i mean i don't know how
many aircraft there are in this
particular mission but
it's a probably multiple aircraft with
all those bombs and they get over the
location
and they just open their bombardier
doors and out come the
other their bay doors and out come the
bombs you know when you see pictures or
videos where there's just
all these airplanes flying there's just
bombs falling out exactly leaking out
yeah just leaking out
that's it suppose the direct support
will come in one or two bombs around the
team this is like
every like jocko saying you may have
four or five planes and
they fly over everything's all bombs are
dropped
over 100 at least yeah there'd be
anywhere to 250
500 000 pounders
blackjack mandolin i don't think
i want to be here or sorry mandolin
blackjack i don't think i want to be
here when they arrive over
blackjack mandolin well you have one
last option
over what is it over unexpectedly
our radio frequency is flooded with
fast-talking vietnamese
god you can't get a break so the
vietnamese figure out what radio
frequency they're on they start using
that
unexpectedly our radio frequency is
flooded with fast talking vietnamese
cowboy listens for a few seconds and
says
nva find our frequency i switch to an
alternate frequency as it is jammed and
it is jammed as well
i throw the prc radio over the cliff and
switch to the urc-10
survival radio mandolin blackjack over
mandolin blackjack over
blackjack jg32 over go jg32
you're on an air force survival guard
frequency
243. covey 265 is busy on other channels
we'll get his attention for you i'm
hovering in a draw to your west
we have 20 minutes of fuel left before i
leave
the first person we see better be an
american hurry
we're taking heavy ground fire our armor
is not holding up this close
to the source jg32 can you hook me up
with covey
blackjack mandolin over mandolin can you
lay down
covering fire between us and jg32 give
me two minutes to line up assets then
move out
we're getting empty the next voice you
hear will be spiders over
roger spider blackjack over
i turn and yell the team alabama discard
everything we don't need
over the side get ready to move out
cowboy and i move to the edge of the
cliff
while lock demands commands the garrison
the two of us cautiously peep over the
edge 15 feet below us is a ledge that
moves in the direction we want to travel
move the team to this location i order
cowboy crawls back to the cadaver
garrison
while i make another attempt at
contacting spider one at a time
alabama comes crawling over to me i
begin lowering each of them to the ledge
below
one one scales the rock face making his
own way out
making his own way immediately beginning
to move along the ledge in the direction
of the
of jg32 cowboy stop him
from the ledge we look up the face of
the cliff
we can see tracers dancing across the
lip of the rim
covey's directing daisy chain air
strikes between
alabama and jg32 blackjack spider
we're dropping cluster bomb unit cbu on
the path between you and jg32
it will kill some and should temporarily
drive the rest out of the zone
man so they want to get to where this
helicopter is located flying in this
little draw
and in order to get there they drop
cluster bombs on their path
yeah for good luck and then that that
jolly green
settled into the jungle chopping down
smaller trees to settle so that way
it's brilliant moving somewhere
protected yes so that way
uh they're not visible not completely
exposed they're going to shoot him they
go
they have to shoot through the jungle to
get to him yeah it's counter-intuitive
when you're in
the air in a helicopter yeah in a
helicopter but i guess on on fast movers
or
aircraft as well you'd think the closer
you get to the ground the more danger
you're in but the opposite is actually
true
because when you get down low enough
people can't shoot at you because they
don't have an angle to shoot at you
whether it's in the
city or whether it's in uh in a jungle
like this people just
they they can't see you anymore because
you're low right so here the helicopters
in the jungle
and then like you said with the with the
a1 skyraiders the key to their success
was how low they made their gun runs
they would just come screaming across
the path
drop their ordinance and be on their way
oh yeah
so anybody's in the jungle you can hear
them coming
you can't see them until it's too late
even for a slow mover like that but oh
we love them
continuing on thick choking smoke
moves across the lz roiling over the
ledge above obscuring our escape from
the plane
from the plane of death we inch our way
toward the last
chance arc lights coming blackjack the
cbu strike has created
negative visibility we're unable to
provide support until we get a window
over
you're looking for a window and i'm
looking for a door spider blackjack
the good news is it has also decreased
visibility for the nva gunfire's
noticeably subsided keep up the smoke
and we'll move by ear hugging the face
of the cliff making our way across the
rubble of the ledge
we come to a dead end crap we're gonna
have to climb back
up to the plateau wait here while i take
a look if it's okay i'll signal
easily climbing with the aid of vines
trailing over the ledge i crawl over one
side
and slide under the low vegetation
seconds later one woods head appears
spotting me he crawls to my location up
under a large
broad leaf plant where's your weapon i
ask i don't know
he sheepishly replies take this ak and
cover us
while i get the rest of the team up here
over can you do that uh-huh
lock the zero one is the last person to
go over the rim joining the remainder of
the team
in the undergrowth giving me two thumbs
up as quickly as the underbrush will
allow
we move up a small incline under the
protection of enormous broad leaf
undergrowth
shortly we come to the periphery of a
short ledge where we stop
before us is a carnivorous half-lit
clearing under
jungle canopy look at this hundreds of
large
huts built up on stilts stretch back
into the low light
everywhere there are trails campfires
and cooking area
cooking areas two are left as a latrine
in a shower facility
smoke from cooking has fires spiral
upward gently mingling with the battle
haze
ceiling drifting just below the canopy
clothes are hung over low plants
and robes strung between towering
hardwood trees
this must be their main camp this is
amazing it's an entire town under the
trees
no one seems to be home from the sounds
of it they must all be over there i say
pointing at the direction of
jg32 look over there who's that who's
that
looks like an american hey you he turns
pointing a 45 caliber pistol in our
direction i stand up motioning him to us
he raises a 45 pistol to his lips
signaling us to be quiet we cautiously
move
to his location who are you i'm the jg
10 pj dan caspier
rotor head is over there under that hut
talking to the 30
talking with 32 who's rotor head i ask
our pilot colonel sam grineer i think he
has a broken back
but he can still walk the other members
of your crew did they make it
10 was burning there was only time to
get out grineer before it exploded our
flight engineer greg lawrence
and co-pilot duane wester were trapped
inside
i didn't have time the pj pauses jg10
exploded before i could get back to them
we've been waiting for you guys here
hoping we would
you would make it before we had to ene
grab rotor head and fall in with the
seven of us now
so so these guys have now just
miraculously ran into the pilot and the
pair rescue guy
that had that was inside that helicopter
that got shot down and then exploded
yeah and the pilot's got a broken back
he's still mobile
yes sir the nva are focused on jg32
easing pressure on us we need to move
there as quickly as possible
32 doesn't have much time left on
station we have to go
now order sam grineer none of us have
much time left
form up we're going home i demand casbir
help your colonel
we can hear them moving through the
jungle all around us they seem to be
traveling to the ship paralleling us
blackjack spider time's against you
buddy
32 can't wait much longer and the arc
light is closing fast
the b-52s have begun their countdown
they're on long
final yeah you can't make this up
no the arc light's coming in to drop
bombs all over everything in the area
the aircraft that they're trying to get
to that could possibly get them home
that's hidden in the jungle is almost
out of fuel
and they can hear as they're moving
towards the helicopter
they can hear they're being paralleled
by the nva
on the move spider arc lights on the way
we intersect a trail running down the
middle of the ravine i stopped the team
helicopter gunships and skyraiders are
making blind gun runs
up and down the narrow ravine and around
jg32
smoke from air strikes hangs over the
plateau
threading its way down the ravines into
the depths of the murky chasm
blackjack spider air strikes to clear
the way is impossible
we can no longer see the jungle let
alone your ride home get a move on over
i feel as though we are moving past mad
dogs guarding the gates of hell itself
nva are pouring small arms fire and
rocket-propelled grenades into the
hovering
chopper while door gunners and pilots
intermittently fire the gatling gun and
m-60s
desperate i moved the team in onto the
trail toward the hovering ship
don't move on a trail you dumbass well
this is one of those times when jungle
rules don't apply
amen so they can see the helicopter they
can see that it's taking fire
there's a trail and you guys and anyone
in vietnam is constantly avoiding the
trails because that's where ambushes and
booby traps get set
but in this situation there's no choice
no choice
we progress hastily tail gunner begins
violently shaking in his turn to pasty
white
to the vietnamese assistant hiding him
in thick bushes
so tail gunner is your rear security guy
and he's
he's the one who's shot in the ground
he's losing blood
he's pale white to the vietnamese assist
hiding him in thick bushes
then they flee to the chopper i stop
them taking lead
at the at the crest we see jg32 taking
hits and dealing out death
it's m60 is red hot someone is firing an
m16 out of rear port
as we move to jg32 the intensity of
gunfire
seems to multiply a hundred fold jesus
the air is so full of lead i can see it
i report to myself loudly
fuel and bits of metal skin are falling
from the aircraft as we approach
on one side of the turbine cowling is
lying on the jungle floor
blackjack spider who are you talking to
over
god buddha anyone that'll listen spider
blackjack sorry i didn't realize i held
the
the radio keyed over the jungle
penetrator from jg's winch smashes into
the ground and then raises a couple feet
pj dan caspier scrambles to put three
team members on the first load
when you get in the chopper man a gun
and return fire protect us i yell after
them
rotor head and pg and the pj along with
quang a wounded
alabama vietnamese are on the second
lift kwang becomes entangled in jungle
vines while being hoisted
the operator has to stop the hoist lower
it to give him time to untangle himself
when the hoist moves up toward the
aircraft cuang is not sitting in the
seat but hanging on
with assistance from casbier quang i
returned tracing
i returned i turned retracing our path
back down the trail
to the thicket where we had left our
tailgunner
halfway back i realize i'm alone with no
weapon
for the first time paralyzing fear
sweeps through me
i stop what am i doing you couldn't help
you when he was hit
but you can quang face the boogie man do
your job [ __ ] move
quang is covered with bloated black
leeches mosquitoes and giant flies
feeding off the last of his ebbing life
mumbling he wobbles his colt 45 at
advancing nva
toy keat i die
the tail gunner motions to me to return
to the jolly green
i turn and kwang shoots himself
you sons of [ __ ] my cry is lost in
the sounds of battle
tears obscure my vision as i scramble
like a raving lunatic
back in the direction of the waiting
ship smack rushing smack into two
screaming nva their aks pointed at me
chew hoy
i surrender surrendering
stretching out my arms continuing to
move quickly in their direction
within arm's reach i yell in their faces
chew hole yourself [ __ ] the
young soldiers are taken by surprise
before they can respond i grab a searing
hot ak-47 barrel jerking the weapon from
one of them
blistered skin rolls off my hand i
backhand the one on my right and smashed
the soldier on my left in the face with
his own weapon
hot hot hot i scrambled to the
penetrator
finding a praying one one on the ground
the rest of the team have abandoned him
and are on board firing any weapon they
can get their hands on
as the penetrator lifts in what seems
like slow motion
one one and i look upward wondering what
the hell is taking so long
we are showered with hot spent m60 and
other
weapon shell casing hot brass is
sticking to my bare skin
creating long water blisters similar to
the ones on my hand from the ak i
grabbed
the air is filled with smoke jet fuel
and green tracers
moving past us in slow motion like mad
hornets
never-ending shell casings raining down
along with metal debris and a tornado of
jungle vegetation
the penetrator cable is vibrating
violently as
jg 32 takes hit after hit it's all
coming apart i yell at one
one jg 32
piloted by lieutenant colonel jim grady
begins lifting
out of the jungle ravine with the two of
us hanging on below like a couple of
crippled puppets
on a quarter-inch steel wire there are
several great trees on both sides of the
ship
all of them large enough to severely
damage the five
62-foot rotors causing it to crash
ascending out of the jungle
we can feel the heat of b40 rocket
motors as they pass by on their way to
slamming into jg-32's
plated underside the ship is being
boosted upward with each explosion
i slump on the penetrator and begin
sliding off as my backside is sprayed
with shrapnel
hey that hurts one one grabs hold
wrapping his arms around me
saving my life hope what's left of the
armor holds
i i weakly yell grasping at the
penetrator cable for balance
the jg flight mechanic reaches out
pulling me off the penetrator into the
ship
dumping me on red hot shell covered deck
with 1-1 on my heels
para-rescue specialist allen avery
leaves his gun position
and begins tending to alabama alabama's
wounds
once clear of the jungle hole the ship
begins its ascent out of the valley
the flight mechanic sergeant john
nussbaum
removes his helmet and places it on my
head co-pilot major don
olson tells me we're on our way out of
here partner
i'm cold
lieutenant an analyst breaks the silence
1-1 do you have anything to add to
blackjack's story
no sir he softly mumbles with his head
down
how many nva do you think were in the
area and how many do you think were
killed or wounded
asks sergeant analysis
i believe the question was directed to
1-1 but before he can muster with an
answer i jump in the answer to both of
those questions is more than we had time
to count
however i'll estimate somewhere between
three to five thousand nva
how many did we kill before we round out
of our ammo we killed hundreds
when we started using their weapons we
killed hundreds more between
us and air support maybe two or three
thousand
the arc light followed that after we
left
i hope they finished off the rest of
them
crazy oh yeah and then that that jolly
green giant
couldn't fly too far it only went over
two more mountaintops
it lands another one comes in picks up
some of the guys
then lynn and the one one had to go back
on the cobra gunship
because the cobra the the the weapon
doors come down
and they have seat belts on them oh my
god so
all the way from layoffs back to the
nang they're with the uh
yeah uh just to just to top everything
off for them
and they froze their balls off of course
because they're dangling out there five
thousand feet
take it up to five thousand feet to get
away from any yes
enemy fire
and and the uh and of course the model
of the jolly greens
that others may live yeah that day
they put it right on the line amazing i
going in after you see multiple birds
shot down like oh one bird goes and gets
shot out the next bird goes and gets
shot out the next bird goes and gets
shot down
yeah and you're still coming in yep
we're here and one got shot so bad
limped back to base barely got back
they continue on with this debrief and
and one of the analysts says tell us
about the terrain again
1-1 you were closer to the terrain than
i was why don't you answer that question
one one breaks down a medical aid gives
him a sedative
to quiet his nerves he's been through a
lot i sigh
do you also need a sedative ask the
medic no thanks i don't handle any kind
of drugs very well
if i take that i'll be asleep in 10
minutes give me an understanding of
where you are
physically and psychologically ask one
of the medics
physically today i'm less than 50
percent
i took some hard hits and i'm still
trying to recover psychologically who
the heck knows
anyone doing this kind of work is
probably crazy from the get-go you know
what i mean
a combat soldier focuses on what they
feel physically what they
see hear and smell feelings of fear
sadness boredom and joy are suppressed
as much as possible
so we can focus on the mission our team
and
staying alive the psychological stuff
has to come later
or we won't make it does that make sense
to you
so there you go this is a classic thing
we're putting off all this stuff like
not worrying about it right now we got a
job to do
the medic looks up from taking notes it
will do for now please continue with
your train of thought
as soon as my wounds fully close and the
stitches come out
i'll begin training again i i heal fast
and definitely have some ideas
on needed training for alabama to be an
effective team
don't you think that's up to the 1-0 to
determine what training is needed for
his team
1-1 perks up i jump in ahead of him
yes sir no sir i mean it's up to all of
us to conduct training
as americans the welfare of a special
forces
team is the responsibility of every man
on that team
if the designated leader can't lead then
it's incumbent on
any one of us to step forward and
provide that leadership
that's what i did and that's what i'll
do again
if needed so there you go
oh yeah real leadership
pure leadership fearless
peerless
so you're ready to go do it again
and he thinks to himself i've heard that
several guys have hung it up after the
first
mission i think i know why
it's these damn debriefs
they were a pain in the ass that's for
sure the analyst continues
our best intelligence indicates there's
probably or i think this is um
yeah this is this is the chief song our
best intelligence indicates that
there's approximately 2 000 miles of
trail and between 12 to 15
bin tram and those are like bin tram is
like these um
organizations what are they like a
battalion sized it was a
longer trail there'd be a command and
control element as well as a hospital
overnight rest facilities and then from
there they run people out to keep the
trails open work with the local
indigenous people
the conscripts because they're
constantly bombing the trail
so these these are organizations along
the trail they're called bin trams
then thousands of anti-aircraft guns 20
to 30
30 000 support soldiers all defended by
40 to 60 000 security troops
that's what we need intel on are you
ready to take another whack at it
chief sog asks half grinning at the two
of us
whiskey tango foxtrot i'm not sure i
really wanted to know that
i will be once the wounds of healed when
i'm in better physical condition
and we get the training that i talked
about and after i have a couple more
beers
tell me about what you thought about out
there ask a tall slender
gray-haired medical officer on the other
side of the table
behind him sits two obvious assistants
taking notes
lynn thinks didn't i just answer the
question a few minutes ago
these guys are not going to let up and
then he says do you mean me
personally yes you personally what went
through your mind
what emotions did you feel how much
detail are you asking for
god i hate that i hate and he thinks
himself
god i hate this how did you feel [ __ ]
didn't i answer that question a few
minutes ago we've heard
excellent tour guide level detail from
the point of the initial ambush to your
team's extraction
tell us about the period of time from
the point of insertion to the ambush
take your time give me a tour of your
thoughts what were you thinking
i lean back in my chair pausing thinking
i'm a guy i'm a guy not some woman who
wants to do nothing but talk about her
feelings
guys don't think about their feelings
this is just his thoughts we're either
happy
sad thirsty horny or hungry
okay calm the hell down and give him an
answer
and then he says i was on the second
king bee we watched bulldog and the
others disembarked from the first ship
just before
our spiral began our door gunner
announced we go down now
chuckles around the room we assumed the
get ready position
with me sitting in the door the lottery
lz cork screwed up to meet us
several feet off touchdown i spotted an
nva flag posted near the edge
i remember thinking oh crap several of
them
laugh or quiet or quietly chuckle what
you spotted freaking nva flag on the
landing zone
yeah i think he goes into a little bit
more detail specialist black i've heard
about the mission i want to know about
your
feelings what you felt emotionally do
you understand
well sir oh crap to me is a pretty
strong feeling
however when a soldier's in that
situation that causes thoughts like oh
crap or others we usually don't
have time to stop and consider our
feelings as soon as our king beat tires
bounced down tracers punched through the
side of our ship we got the hell out of
there
i remember thinking what a mistake that
was actually sir it was more like we are
screwed
blackjack the sergeant major objects yes
sergeant major
in mid liftoff the green swarm engulfed
the ship like a disturbed nest of horns
the king bee hung in midair laboring
slipping to its left the pilot wrestling
with a stick his co-pilot was slumped in
a seat down it went in a ball of flames
the two scarface ships providing cub
provided covering fire
as i moved my portion of alabama to link
up with the 1-0
i yelled the bulldog that we needed to
get off the lz he ordered us to form up
we quickly moved in a low crouch through
the knee-high razor grass to a log
where bulldog and the others were we
were knee-deep in kimchi
and i knew it
and there's a little bit of a of a
a little bit of a tension between um
between
uh bulldogs yeah between bulldog
and and blackjack
and with that tension and i'm fast
forward a little bit
he said uh did it make the one of the
analysts says did it make you angry
angry how did it make you feel i didn't
care i came back here to do a job
why did you come back the medical
officer insists
because they nailed my brother and best
friend and several the guys in my 173rd
unit
i came back here to get even is that
what you want to know am i mad
no when i got out of the first when i
got out the first time
and went home it bugged me that so many
of us had been killed or wounded and i
couldn't really say i had seen the enemy
i felt like a failure i'm gonna fight
in a war if i'm gonna fight in a war i
wanna see the enemy i wanna look on
their face when i pull the trigger
or i have them roasted with napalm are
you getting what you need with this
answer
and then he thinks to himself don't ask
me this [ __ ] again i'm here doing a job
that most of the guys back home don't
want to do just be satisfied
you can get people like me who want to
be up here and are qualified
yes thank you the medical officer
deadpans
black continue on with the narration
instructs lieutenant
analyst and with feeling he snorts
again this whole scene is just straight
out of a freaking hollywood
movie of you know the
the the combat soldier fresh off the
battlefield getting interrogated by
these
ramps yeah and even there like the whole
thing with the flag
and experience one zero would have gone
but said no we're out of here
they had a green one zero and lynn try
to
i don't i think if he goes to the
details yeah he goes into it a little
bit
um but he wouldn't listen there was just
a couple like that little bit of
disagreement
you know why did sgt stride make you the
radio operator
one two and black the one one he goes
through this you know
um uh
so he continues here um
yes sir covey asked for a sit rep at
which time i reported that the second
king bee was shot down
and we were waiting for bulldog to make
a go no goku decision
mandolin asked a talk with bulldog
who said he was going to continue with
the mission he then motioned to our
point man
to move over to a well-traveled trail
across the lz
into the jungle cowboy point the
vietnamese team leader
lock and i vigorously argued against
walking a trail especially when we had
already made contact to be honest
i thought the order was stupid there i
said it
and he's thinking to himself there i
said it you want to know how i feel
that's it so this is when you're the
tension that we were talking about oh
yeah
lieutenant analyst his face red eyes
narrowed you argued with your 1-0 in the
middle of making contact with the enemy
and then lin thinks to himself your ass
is in trouble now keep calm he's never
been in a combat situation except maybe
fighting with his older sister
the first rule of recon is never use
trails
especially well-traveled trails that
trail i said to stride
definitely fits that category he told me
he was in command
and that i would follow his orders
without questions did you
yes sir into really deep
kimchi continue the chief orders
impatiently
bulldog angrily motioned to the team to
move up
on the trail point leading the way with
bulldog pushing from behind on his
rucksack
the trail wound into dense jungle
foliage bending to the left
point tried to move cautiously
paralleling a small team
a small 10 to 20 foot rise to our right
bulldog hurried him along pushing
pushing him to his death
is that statement necessary the
lieutenant analyst sarcastically cracks
i was instructed to tell you what i was
personally thinking i was the only
american on the team with vietnam
experience with combat experience
i was the fourth person in line right
behind cowboy
i think sergeant stride's experience
went back to an a-team in korea
and 1-1 had never seen combat is that
statement necessary i think so yes
rank and combat experience are not
necessarily synonymous
don't you agree and he says sometimes
stay calm stay calm
point taken how did you feel when taking
fire on insertion
asks the doc when we took fire going in
i felt
anxious he thinks to himself that's an
understatement scared the [ __ ] out of me
that anxiety turned to disbelief when
bulldog made the decision to continue
the mission
and then again when the decision was
made to walk a trail
i remained on the state of higher alert
high alert right up to the ambush
an interesting thing happened they all
laughed
we can imagine people were killing your
teammates and you were pinned down how
much more interesting could it get
observes sergeant analyst they all
nervously laugh again
i sit silent expressionless
looking into each of their eyes the
medical
officer is quietly observing me after
what seems like a long time i turn and
look at the one one
his head is down his hands folded in his
lap
whiskey tango foxtrot over i think to
myself
turning back to the debrief panel you
ever been ambushed
i asked flatly chief sog and the command
sergeant major
both shift uncomfortably in their chair
none of them have
my impatience my impatience with this
process is giving way to temper
i'm tired remember what covey said keep
your cool
all these questions have been covered in
our initial debrief and documented in
the aer
what are these guys after give them what
they want and then get the hell out of
here
then he starts speaking again when the
nva triggered the ambush
all that anxiety disappeared i went to
work previous experience and training
kicked in
i returned fire with the intent of
suppressing the nva attack
and being able to maneuver out of the
spot we were in bulldog was
bulldogging 1-1 was down like i said
before
i thought he was hit and took charge
i've learned the best defense is an
aggressive offense
as long as we had ammunition and could
move i took charge of our not so little
not
no name battle moving at will causing as
much confusion for the enemy as possible
preventing them from forming up a large
force to overrun us
that tactic worked until we ran out of
ammo
the anxiety returned
no sir fear one one turns to face me
with local dis
disbelief how did you deal with it
prompts the doctor
our situation seemed impossible the fact
is
i was completely overcome with fear for
an instant i couldn't move
and he thinks to himself i haven't
thought about this until now i don't
know if i can express that feeling
he continues oddly it seemed to be
unconnected to the physical danger the
fear
yes there were three things going on all
at once
it was this it was as if i had stepped
outside myself
seeing all things feeling all emotions
all at the same time in that instant
i became completely demoralized
and he thinks to himself every person in
this room is fixed on what i am saying
i wish i knew what i was saying or how
to say it i'm talking like a woman
or like to shrink
demoralized the doc gently urges
what made the emotion so overpowering
was the realization that i had violated
every moral precept of my upbringing
my childhood focused sharply blending
into the present
i couldn't wrap my mind around our deeds
i was alive
we were alive hundreds of others were
dead fathers
sons husbands you know more would die
maybe thousands i raised my hand to hold
off further questions as i stared down
at the table to focus my thoughts and
emotions
emotions here they are that he continues
that entire thought process lasted a
fraction of a second
then the usual if i can call it that
the re-emergence of our deadly danger
the possibility of a sudden assault and
total annihilation
was welcome and composing reality
pacified me
our reality emerged in my mind like a
clap of
thunder my emotions were out prioritized
by mortality
you might want to talk with us about
with you might want to talk
with one of our medical staff offers the
chief sog
and he thinks i just did there's nothing
they can do for me ignoring his comment
it's interesting to watch the changes in
people who are on the spot
for instance in that fraction of a
second when the concussion grenade hit
me
i became interesting to myself
what does that mean interested in
yourself the medical officer is
surprised
not interested in myself but interesting
to myself an object of interest outside
myself
it's difficult to describe however all
that serves no purpose in the moment
distractions of that kind prevent us
from witnessing
our own death from dealing with the
present
someone on the team mentioned
surrendering
we all knew they would kill us
good thinking offers the command
sergeant major anyway
that led to a conversation about
breaking the team into two man groups to
escape
and evade at that point in the battle we
felt the terrain
and enemy activity prevented us from end
that's when we decided to fight it out
using
our using their weapons during daylight
hours and then try to get some of the
people
out under the cover of darkness we now
had options
and resolve the fear was diminished
and a new purpose and mission had
gripped every man on the team
explain orders the lieutenant analyst
i thought i just did blackjack
chides the sergeant major okay okay i
hesitate looking for the words
during daylight hours we decided to
fight them as hard as we could using
their weapons and
tactics i know from experience
that when you use the enemy's tactics
against them they are
they quickly become confused have you
ever considered
counter measures against your own
tactics of course not no one ever does
you're not going to fight yourself right
that's why it's so important for us to
study their tackets and
tactics and use those tactics against
them in the field
the reports saigons send out each month
are the basis for that knowledge
along with what we learned directly in
the field practical experience
you all are here making a major
contribution to us staying alive
and being successful what you have told
me about
being trans today adds to that knowledge
they're smiling shooting approval
glances at one another
and then he thinks to himself blackjack
you're being a kiss ass
knock it off thank you specialist black
for the performance review of my staff
replies the chief's
sog with a straight face please continue
instantly they all get serious
all we had to do is hold out until dark
what about the b-52 strike that was on
the way mocks the lieutenant analyst
minor consideration if thousands of
enemy couldn't kill us 20 feet from
20 feet away we could certainly live
through b-52's bombing
from 20 or 30 000 feet the lt gives me
his narrowed
eyed narrow-eyed i don't believe you
look as the medical officer and others
suppress their laughter
we begin to pair up as the curtain of
death fell around
us even though we were still acting as a
team
curtain of death asks the medical
officer quizzically
i remember that when the decision was
made i felt as if a black curtain were
being lowered around me
it was something i could see in my mind
we made every attempt to maneuver
ourselves into an e
e launch position which turned out to be
the route we took to the last
jolly green giant we figured
because we were small and they were so
large at night we would have
they would have to set up blocking
positions and not move on us
the reasoning was that if they tried to
move they would wind up shooting each
other
in large blocking groups they would make
noise revealing themselves and their
positions
this would give us the opportunity to
try and move out between those positions
and get out
it's a good thing we didn't have to e e
at night using that route it would have
led us directly into the heart of their
camp
my job became getting as many of my team
off the battlefield
and out of the ao to safety as possible
black your alabama team is very lucky
you didn't have to e e because the b-52
strikes even if you survived them the
nva would have taken
to widely dispersing its units for
instance a 2000 man
nva regiment might spread might be
spread across a five
mile stretch of trail dug in into each
bend
in the road and hilltop this is by the
way of explaining
this is by the way of explaining why
some sog
teams just vanish unwittingly landing
amid
such an overlapping concentration of nva
forces
my guess is that no matter which way you
would have turned every half mile or so
you would have bumped into enemy
platoons or companies
even 500 man battalions
looking directly at chief sogg
did you know they were all there at that
place we chosen
as an lz without hesitation he responds
so so you got lynn saying wait a second
bro
you knew that there was all these people
on the freaking ground that we were
going to put in an lz
and the chief song says no not
specifically the 12 teams before alabama
were tracking a regiment down the trail
that tracking mission as you know became
known as the lottery
we believe you found that regiment and
ben tram those these these organizations
that protect the ho chi minh trail ben
tram 611
at that same location our intelligence
led us to believe
that your lz was approximately five
miles from that base and that alabama
might have a chance at gathering very
important intel along the network of
trails so prevalent in that area
the fact is we now know exactly where
bimtran
bin tram 611 was located
and you have confirmed the type and
number of personnel on site
rarely is such a small team engage such
a large force with
so few casualties and live to tell about
it the ben tram
611 you all encountered has been
destroyed
for now along with the regiment that
took 12
sog teams we here are all
all very proud to work with men like you
and your alabama team
blackjack is there anything else you
want to say asks
sergeant analyst anything at all
yes the jolly green
giants the motto painted on the sides of
their ships
so that others may live
emotion wells up give me a minute please
the thought of the jg's the vietnamese
king bees
and all the others who have committed
their lives to saving
alabama emotionally inundate my senses
overpowering my ability to stuff
emotions back down
my my eyes flood with tears
we're alive today due to all of you
thank you
amen man
yeah and and by the way so
that right there is page 60. that that
just got us to page 60 of this book
of this 300 page book
that's one mission
one historic sog mission one one mission
one historic mission but a mission that
represents another day
in sauk which was the saying that you
guys had
yeah many like that that was in a
special category
yeah yeah but the i mean the setup
that's what you guys did
you know like the setup hey like we're
gonna go in there we're gonna find out
where the bad guys are
we're taking the king bees in we'll call
for fire support if we get in trouble
that was your that was your model that
was your that was what you guys did
oh yeah
although if we saw a flight we would
definitely try to get out of there if we
could
post haste how about when you're taking
massive fire on insert what about that
one
is that another thing that you just shot
down a good idea or one of your insert
craft gets shot down you say we're going
to continue the mission
can you imagine no dang
well there's a ton of other missions
to discuss this book it's called whiskey
tango foxtrot is written by lynn black
jr
just get the book and a bunch of the
other missions there i want to save some
of them
so hopefully we can get we can get the
man himself on here
uh to talk through some of these give us
his experiences and it's also cool
because we'll get both you guys on here
because
you know he writes about some of the
same missions you guys were on together
and you guys both wrote about these
missions so to get both you in here to
kind of go through those
um i'll do my job shut up and just let
you guys talk which would be freaking
awesome awesome to do um
but yeah hopefully we can get him on at
some point and if not then we'll if he
does if he can't make it on then we'll
we'll go through
some of these other stories and and
share them well it's an honor to pay
homage to him he's just a great guy
fearless warrior and some of the things
he did in that mission
oh my god when you think about these
times
was it seem like it seemed like a long
time ago does it seem like yesterday or
and i'm going to ask you this does it
seem like both because for me
sometimes my experience seems like it
was a long time ago and sometimes it
seems like it was yesterday
what does it seem like to you oh it's
clearly both yeah absolutely because
i can just remember us standing there at
the outside the s3 shop waiting for the
go
for the bright light because don already
told us
and we were switching everything out
that's nothing but ammo hand grenades
and bandages
and some body bags and uh
quite glad that they changed their mind
lynn you know
again he had this right tactical
decision
on the ground and he called it right
because if we tried to go in
just like his the other helicopter shot
down and there's more people on the
ground more casualties possibly
and so yeah so that day comes back every
october 5th
you know we have our little email loop
spider pat watkins
and they always go hey lin this is your
day brother
we don't know how you did it but we're
glad you did
yeah the fact that you know
he's he's saying in the beginning when
they inserted like they should have left
immediately
meaning he's kind of looking to save his
own ass right
for sure god bless him but then you fast
forward whatever it is a few hours
and now he's saying nope i'm saving
everyone else's ass don't come and get
me
i mean that's hey don't land your bird
he calls off
king bees get out of here don't take off
leave us here
bright light no don't send them we're
not going to be bait
yeah and you know when he when he
finally came back to base like a day or
two later they had to go patch him up
and then they had a little um ceremony
with the air force guys where they
swapped rays
because the pjs had their brains on i
think lynn and
steve swapped out theirs and
when he came back to base he never
talked about it
we we'd heard about what spider and
mandolin are saying
about the mission but you know lynn
wouldn't talk about it
so even when i did the book i had to go
back and physically go come on then i
want to
get this story into the books i flew up
to the night 1980
90 finally interviewed that's when i
learned stuff that i never knew
about the mission already some of the
little details about the um
finding the pj cooking the broken back
and oh my god so he's just an amazing
amazing uh
warrior great guy and an artist on top
of it
and when he was talking about the chief
sog that was steve kavanagh
who was a highly decorated world war ii
vet and then when korea he was in
germany but then he was chief sog he
came in right after jack singlob
and his welcome to sag was august 23rd
68 f of b4
yeah so he was a really good chief song
he really cared about the men but uh
what was his rank
as the chief sog bert oh six so he was a
full bird colonel
and he was in charge of and he's in
charge of all sock
ccn ccs and ccc all of our operations
and then um see this is again the
regular army
instead of having a general that could
go do battle with other generals
they had a colonel part of the in-house
fighting with the boys down in saigon
and so that's why i love the book
because ling gets into this little
exchange it's back and forth and he has
little
his editorials on my comments with these
oh yeah
it's so freaking classic it's precious
it's crazy because i know you yeah and
so i'm reading tilt said this and tilt
said that
tilt's throwing this it's so awesome to
read
yeah it's freaking awesome he also you
know it he also breaks into the whole
you get to you get a better you get a
very good feeling of
the whole kind of deployment when he's
going into town
and he's there's all kinds of shady kind
of cia stuff going on in there that he's
wrapped up in
oh yeah that's free it's like it's legit
well and even in the first 60 pages
there are segments there
for what he did under fire
that could be cut out and used in any
leadership school
for the military anywheres it's just
incredible stuff
yeah not to mention anything that he did
multiple times over could be used to
write an awards citation what did he
what did he receive for this well he
wound up with a silver star
okay which should have been my opinion
at least a medal of honor
and because in the book he goes into it
spider
and mandolin are talking a little bit a
few days later
and the s3 officer a major
who will remain nameless um was saying
he didn't bring back stride so you'd be
glad we put him in for a silver star
and you know pat walkers and spider were
pretty emphatic it should have been a
lot higher than that
and we could think about medal of honors
that had been awarded
where nothing like what lynn was up
against getting knocked out
all that time on the job patching up his
own people
and then leading them out and then oh
we'll just charge right through the nva
ranks they're not used to that
oh my god it's weird because
he's uh definitely a cerebral guy as you
could hear from that last section
oh yeah but damn he would get aggressive
i mean he's his whole he's pissed off
that's kind of one of the reasons he
re-enlisted because he's pissed off
that they wounded his brother and
wounded people from the 173rd and killed
people from 173rd
so he's got this like pent-up
progression but then he's an artist
oh yeah right sure he worked at this tv
station during high school he's so good
but i want to you know we we just read
it so
and then uh years later i mean
he just comes back in his own way and he
goes gets a job at boeing
rises through the ranks just did
incredible work there that nobody could
talk about
oh yeah damn one of our sog legends to
the max
and humble and modest he's just like
pulling teeth again to talk about it
yeah that's why i love the book you know
every once in every couple years so i
pulled out and re-read it
do you know what what inspired him to
write this book
that's a good question i don't know um
these last 15 years or so between the
reunions and
uh being so far apart
i was just everybody was talking to come
on lenny got to the book
and at one point he told him he threw
away four to 500 pages
i said lin please tell me you just put
them in a little
folder somewhere give them to me or give
them to somebody
and they said no it's done
so he worked on for a while he really
did and we had chatted back and forth
back when i stole the newspaper back in
the day
well it's it's a it's a phenomenal book
i hope everybody goes to pick it up
hopefully you can come on here
and and talk through some of these
stories and if not that then
hopefully i can just go shake his hand
one day because it'd be an honor indeed
next time you go up to seattle area for
one of your shows yeah
yeah um with that
look we've been going for three and a
half hours or something like that really
yeah yeah i know this must be a jocko
podcast
quit harassing me uh
yeah and and we're gonna come back we'll
do some sog chronicles next
um yeah
until then uh i'm a little bit
speechless but it's
obviously it's an honor to share these
stories these songs stories it's honor
always to have you
until uh an honor to know you and it's
an honor for me to help get the word
about
get the word out about you and your
brothers
in sog your books that you've written
that we've covered on the podcast across
the fence
that's the first one on the ground and
then sog chronicles
volume one you're also out there
just getting after the social media
a little bit now when i get to tennessee
we're going to be moving here real soon
then we're going to get really serious
i'll be calling up echo for some uh
for some skill sets you're on uh you're
on twitter but you don't do much on
twitter
minimal on twitter you're on twitter
you're at sog
john does that one and and then there's
that sog chronicles there's
j striker okay meyer
that's the other handle but see this is
twitter and do you think i should really
be honest you have to give me more
advice here
uh echo depends on what you do i guess
yeah instagram
has been amazing yeah i know that's so i
was going to say jaystriker meyer
on instagram that's where you're at um
you also have
facebook john striker meyer and you have
on the internet on the interwebs you're
at
or it's just sog chronicles.com
correct and we're going to get a get my
uh
20th century websites going to be
upgraded here in the next month or two
look like you designed that one on a
tape recorder
it wasn't that advanced jacob
[Laughter]
my daughters are on me and anna's on me
too so we we're lining up a gentleman
now we're interviewing him to come back
and
redesign absolutely well
like i said thank you so much for coming
on my pleasure and uh
always an honor appreciate it and it's
just
every time you send me a text message
that says airborne it gives me enough
motivation to get through like
six weeks of mayhem
thanks appreciate it until next time
airborne indeed
and with that john striker meyer tilt
has left the building
and you know echo
it's you know we're sitting here and
sometimes we feel like maybe we're
getting after it
and then you sit down with someone like
tilt
and you hear the story of lynn black and
the guys from sog
and it makes me realize that
we can do more and we actually
should do more
with our lives to get after it more
so what recommendations do you have to
keep us
in the mode of getting after it as we
pursue
as we pursue
improvement yeah improvement i just
wanted to say as we improve as we as we
pursue
an unattainable standard yes it's an
unattainable standard
i'm not ever i mean something would have
to go completely haywire for me to get
after it to the level
of a john striker meyer or of uh
lynn black or of a dick thompson there'd
have to be there's
something's got to go majorly wrong so
and i don't you know look we hope that
doesn't happen in the world
so what we are in the pursuit
of that level we're not going to get
there but we're trying yes because we're
not just going to sit back and say oh
they got after it more than me i'm just
going to sit on the couch no
no we're not doing that no we are going
to
get after it appropriate
at the appropriate level to our world
anyway
okay well we do i like the fact that you
finally came to a self-realization of
what you just said made no
sense you don't do that you don't get
that self-realization very often
it makes sense you just got to think
about it that's all just got to think
about it more anyway
so yes we're working out our bodies
degeneration regeneration as you said
wise man jocko
wise man i'm saying i'm saying it okay
there you go boom
uh the the beatings
are the darkness the gains are the light
so
choco fuel this will help you these
things will help you
chocolate fuel we've got stuff for your
joints stuff for your muscles
stuff for your brain stuff for your
immunity
all this stuff some bases you've got
some bases covered yes sir
yes we do anyway joint warfare and krill
oil these for your joints there's
antioxidants in there
too by the way also discipline multi
multiple forms deployment methods
powder mixable in water recommended
maybe throw some juice in there no
all right well hey i was just seeing it
i know that
i mixed one up the other day because it
has been it's been hot here
in the california ao area of operations
and i did you see what i i posted it
what
i mixed up i took just you know well i
don't know if you know this
when it's hot out iced tea yeah arnold
palmer
scenarios yeah are very nice
to have so you know those you ever seen
one of those big
basically this it's a big picture you
know what a picture is
yes it's a clear plastic picture yeah
and there's only one true purpose for
that thing and that is to mix up
iced tea or arnold palmer on a hot hot
day
so i did it emptied my ice thing into
there put in the jacko palmer discipline
go what the can no no the powder that's
not discipline go
put in the discipline powder
it was so good it was nice it was so
good yeah so you got the arnold palmer
jacko palmer you got the arnold palmer
feel
with the jackal palmer feel
even though it didn't make any sense it
made sense see that's what i'm talking
about
so all i had to do was think about it
hey look i'm not this one up
guy you know you don't wanna you know
what a one-up guy is right i'm not that
and i'm not a curse i'm not a grammar
nazi and i'm not a corrector
okay i'll help i'll correct you if you
want you just corrected me on discipline
but okay whatever you have your weird
self-image that's kind of why i kind of
said it because i might have came off
like a corrector and i might come off
like a little bit of a corrector right
now but
technically you have a pitcher hot
summer time
california heat wave weekend that's kind
of what it was
you want a glass pitcher oh no not a
plastic yeah yeah ideally from an ideal
standpoint
i don't know yeah no i agree with you
there you go i
don't purchase the pictures in my house
there you go other people run that part
of the
machine yeah no worries we'll get some
people on the phone we'll sort it out
all good
either way good luck with that yes sir
yes sir either way again things for
immunity vitamin d
and cold war these are two things
different methodologies but
immune support yeah i get on that for
sure because you know in these times
immunity is always a good thing it's
never a bad thing immunity
yeah as far as you know else is a good
thing dessert
yeah dessert being able to drink you
know you eat a nice ribeye
or a nice piece of elk and you're like
oh that was so good but there's still a
little something
in your weird brain yeah that wants
dessert
yeah which is why we make milk yes we
make dessert for you
yep and you can just have a dessert
short
you could have ice cream you could have
carrot cake you could have uh
you could have chocolate pudding or you
could have mulk
it all tastes the same genre of food
except for all those things are bad for
you except milk which is
literally good for you literally good
for you man will supply you with
additional protein
you think a cake is going to give you
more protein a regular cake we will go
toe-to-toe cake versus favorite protein
taste
taste and protein levels
yeah all day so yeah get that one now
and uh your kids gonna like it too
whether it's that one or the warrior kid
malt yeah which there is
the kid's gonna like both of those i
know from experience kids like
this this i know from experience kids
love this
stuff yes sir it's true it's all cheap
also chocolate white tea yes you know
little refreshing
tea scenario anyway you can get all the
stuff at the vitamin shop if you want to
go out and get some also if you don't
want to go
out and get some just go online origin
main
dot com that's where you get it also at
origin main
dot com you can get american made
products straight up american-made hard
goods
hard goods durable goods durable goods
all that all that all that and it's all
made of
keys for those jiu-jitsu you can get
rash guards also for the jiu-jitsu or
other forms of working out
or surfing although we are moving into
the
winter months you might need a wetsuit
but that's up to you we do not make
wetsuits yes yet
t-shirts jeans boots
basically you need clothes to wear i
mean look here's the deal
we need clothes to wear yeah if you're
going to get clothes to wear yes get
them from origin main they're made in
america
we got a bunch of awesome people up
there rebuilding
rebuilding a whole industry in maine
support america and get the best
possible clothing you can
that's that's what we're talking about
yeah it's true and they have some shorts
that for whatever reason
i don't know why they don't talk about
the shorts because it's literally
aside from board shirts like when i swim
and work out or whatever
these are the only shorts i wear the
shark fan
you like the shark fin yeah that's uh uh
pete
yeah that's naming things
it's a very creative namer and i to be
honest what do you think came first
because the
the shark fin shorts has like a pocket
on it that kind of looks like a shark
fin
yeah yeah they didn't know that yeah
yeah cool so i don't know if he
started to design it that way and then
named it the shark fin and then made it
look more like a shark fin
right it's functional there's a reason
for it but i'm just saying
well either way to me shark finn
sounds cool straight up so i was like
hell yeah shark fin shirts
shorts yeah anyway very good good stuff
originate.com all made in america
speaking of shorts
speaking of shorts we it's looking a
board short so we have ford shorts
deathcore to the core discipline equals
freedom
board shorts at joccostore.com
and jacquelinestore.com if you didn't
know it is the store
it's the store where you can get stuff
while you're with you know why you want
to if you want to represent on the path
is where you can get your shirts you
just link with freedom shirts
hoodies board shorts like i said
but did you did what do you call it did
you camo did you cammy did you cammy
and did you cammy did you cammy oh i
don't know i don't know how i've said it
digital camera i think i call it digicam
did you cam
no digicam is a camera
either way camouflage digital you know
that one anyway go to
dockerstore.com like i said if you see
whatever shorts you want what
the camouflage one or the regular
straight up black one
whichever one you want boom available
also some girl stuff on there some uh
some tank tops like that hoodies hats
all this stuff uh if you like something
hey man get something
yeah and don't forget about the uh
warrior kid
soap just well there's warrior kid soap
actually yes
and then there is a bunch of other soap
that is made by a warrior kid
yes young aiden oh we sell it on jocko's
store there's warrior kids soap there's
chocolate soap there's trooper soap and
there's killer soap
all good legitimate soaps but for the
month of september
uh irish oaks ranch will be donating one
dollar per bar of soap to
the cure search foundation it's called
curacao it's a cancer research center
see i'm saying so yeah because cancer uh
awareness month september
so we're donating one dollar per bar of
soap sold
that's a young aiden that's a young
aiden up there
making that happen so there's a kid i
think he might be 14 now
but started this company started this
company wore your kid out there getting
after it and he wants to help out kids
that have cancer so good for him
appreciate the support for that one
don't forget to subscribe to this
podcast
don't forget that we have some other
podcasts the jocko
unraveling podcast which used to be
called the thread
we got quite a few episodes coming out
of that
we have the debrief podcast which is on
this thread on the jocko podcast uh what
is it called feed
for right now we have the grounded
podcast we have the warrior kid podcast
we also have a youtube channel which
which echo makes youtube videos for
jocko podcast youtube channel also
psychological warfare
it's an it's an album with tracks jocko
tracks helping you through moments
of weakness as they may arise maybe not
every day
but they arise sometimes i think you
might have just reached your breaking
point
that's the first time that you've said
that and you've repeated that thing that
you didn't have any enthusiasm or you
had that you had you know you had some
enthusiasm but it was lower well
you know uh so all the times because
just by the way
my enthusiasm for you saying that ended
after about four times
so now we're on what are we on 200
something podcast what are you saying
that
jocko album with track bubble right yeah
so so maybe
we'll you'll think of it something else
to say that the world
hopes the world is hoping i'm i'm
searching my brain to to
to connect the dots they're like i
didn't i don't feel like i'm any
breaking point in any capacity
but i just broke up right here
apparently i am
but so may maybe i'm gonna assume that
you're right yeah soon
maybe it's because
recently i haven't needed psychological
warfare help
okay so it's not like fresh on my mind
okay you know so maybe it came off like
a broke or listen to it well why don't
you go and listen to the track that's
about doing things that you might not
want to do
okay because apparently you think you
can just come in here and kind of slough
off
on your execution yeah on the
psychological warfare part
dang that's kind of what he called that
ironic that's ironic
all right so you can get that if you
want it there's also a
flipsidecanvas.com
my brother dakota myers my brother my
brother dakota myers company
where he sells visual representation did
you hear that i've said that a bunch of
times but you still hear
some spirit in my voice because i'm
fired up when i'm talking about dakota
meyer
and flipsidecanvas.com for visual
representation
that you want to see something if you're
if you feel like maybe you've
broken like echo has you can hang one of
these things up
go to flipsidecampus.com for that we
also got a bunch
of books whiskey tango foxtrot by lynn
black that's what we went over today
also john striker meyer books across the
fence on the ground
those are two different books and then
sog chronicles
we also have the code the evaluation and
protocols
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
way of the warrior kid one two and three
mikey and the dragons discipline equals
freedom field manual
and then extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership
so there's a bunch of books if you want
to support you can go on to
jackalpodcast.com and any of the books
that have been on this podcast
you can get them from there and if
you're wondering hey people always ask
what's the give me the top seven books
that you've read
well they always ask these questions
right reading lists yeah can you hey do
you have a reading list can you publish
reading this yes
i can i already did it's called
jackopodcast.com books from the podcast
you can go on there and if you want to
if you want to you can click
through there and you can go to amazon
and you can actually buy that book
and then you can read it and make
yourself smarter and better
we also have an leadership consultancy
called echelon front where what we do is
solve problems through leadership if you
want to hear me
talk to you if you want me to come and
talk or present
to your team you don't have to go to you
don't have to google
jocko speaking you can just go to
echelonfront.com if you want to have
myself or any of the echelon front
instructors
come and help you come and consult with
you about your leadership get you all
aligned get you on the right path we can
do it
go to echelonfront.com
we also have ef online which listen
if you're wondering hey how can i really
like to know this
my thing from jocko you want to ask me a
question
go to ef online come on monday
wednesday or friday and chances are i
will be there
and if i'm not there someone else from
the echelon front team is but usually
i'm there
i will be there to answer your questions
whatever you want to ask me there's also
a bunch of
in-depth granular studies of all the
principles
from extreme ownership the dichotomy of
leadership and leadership strategy and
tactics
so go to efonline.com
also we have the muster we had one
in orlando canceled we had one in
phoenix cancelled the next one is going
to be
in dallas texas on december 3rd and 4th
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to come
and of course we have ef overwatch if
you need executive leadership
you can get experienced military leaders
that understand the principles that we
talk about
go to efoverwatch.com
and then america's mightywarriors.org
that is
mama lee mark lee's mom and what she
does
is she helps she helps
service members service members that are
downrange
she helps service members families she
helps retired
service members and she helps gold star
families around the world so if you want
to help out with that
you can go to america's
mightywarriors.org
to donate or to get involved and if you
need to contact
us or you have any questions or you have
any answers
you can find us on the interwebs once
again for tilt for john striker meyer
he's on twitter at sog john
he's on instagram at j striker
k e s-t-r-y-k-e-r m e y e
r and facebook john striker meyer and on
the interwebs
at sog chronicles and of course
for us two knuckleheads echo is at echo
charles
and i am at jocko willink and to all of
the military personnel out there that
swore
the oath to put country above self
thank you and to tilt and to lin black
[Music]
and the rest of these sog forces in
vietnam
we can't say thank you enough for doing
what you did so
that others may live
and to police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all other first responders
thanks to you as well for swearing your
oath to take care of us
here on the home front
and everyone else out there think of the
incredible odds that these sog
soldiers went up against and they did it
time and time
and time again in those forgotten
jungles
on those forgotten hills in that
forgotten world
they sacrificed so much
and we must never forget
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out